Welcome to Android Dev Summit
2018.  Welcome to Android Dev
Summit 2018.  Welcome to Android
Dev Summit 2018.  Welcome to
Android Dev Summit 2018.
>> Everyone, please welcome to
the stage, Dave Burke.
[Applause]
Hey, everyone. And welcome to
the 2018 Android
Developer Summit.  This is an
event for developers, by
developers, with tons of
in-depth content and most
importantly, direct access to
the engineers.  We have so many
of them here this week that I'm
pretty sure Android
development's going to stop.
We have attendees from over 70
countries, both in-person and on
the livestream.
Now, speaking of history, it was
-- we're about to celebrate our
10th anniversary of Android and
it was about 10 years ago that
customers were unboxing their G1
devices.  There's huge potential
for the G1, developers create
more applications for Google
Android.
It did okay.  But it's what came
next and what you built on
Android that fundamentally
changed the mobile industry.
10 years ago, the mobile
landscapes looked very
different.
Mobile platforms were not
friendly.  Each OS required
completely different and
non-transferrable skills so it
was impossible to build a mobile
app at-scale.
In building 44, a small team of
dedicated engineers were quietly
working on a crazy project.  The
idea was bold.  To build a new
open source operating system
that any device maker could use
with a powerful SDK that put
developers first.  To many at
the time, this seemed like a
hair-brained idea.  What did
Google know about
telecommunications and how could
it possibly influence this
established industry?
It was an intense time for the
Android team.  And to add to the
drama, while getting close to
launching version 1.0, Apple
announced the iPhone.  We had
the sooner device and the Dream
device, which included a
touchscreen.  We had no choice
to accelerate the schedule.  We
felt like we had a window to
deliver on our vision of the
smartphone before it launched.
So we started a tradition of
putting on a huge breakfast in
building 44.  Bacon, eggs,
pastries, you name it.  And it
was super productive.  No
meetings, just coding.  And in
parallel, release planning.
These cats do not know about
Android Studio's code
completion.
You would have a previous week's
version of Android, but by the
evening, notification would
appear.  It was like watching
the OS come alive before your
eyes.
One of the big challenges is the
bootstrapping problem.  And why
would a user buy a phone with no
applications?  So, we did two
things.  First, the core Android
team wrote mobile app versions
of Google's desktop services
from gmail to Maps to YouTube.
We experienced the framework at
the same time.
But to make the platform shine,
we needed apps from across the
industry.  We launched an
early-look SDK and announced the
Android developer challenge,
with $20 million to be awarded.
Developers responded and by
April 2008, we had over 2,000
submissions.
And it was amazing, given there
were no physical devices, just
the emulator.  The apps were
surprisingly diverse from games
to social networks and utilities
and location and GPS were the
top-used features, along with
camera and media and messaging.
So it really showed this pent-up
demand for developers to be
creative on mobile and use
features.
Some of the winning apps are
still around today, like
Life360.  It paved the way for
apps and businesses.  The
T-Mobile G1 launched.  It was
the predecessor to Google Play
and it had over 50 apps on day
one.  One week later, we opened
this door for developer uploads
and advanced capabilities like
in-app purchases and broader
country support were yet to be
built.
The following 10 years was one
of rapid evolution.  In the
early days, we were doing two
big releases a year and our lead
program manager, at the time,
made this off-hand suggestion
that we code name it after
desserts and that idea stuck and
here's what came next.  So,
Android 1.5, Cupcake, we were
eating a lot of Cupcakes at the
time, adding virtual keyboard
support so we no longer required
the physical keyboard.  We added
the copy and paste.
There were different screen
densities and sizes, thereby
laying factors that will come a
couple years later.  That was
Diane Hackborn's idea.
Android 2 Eclair changed driving
forever with Google Maps
navigation.
Froyo had voice actions, which
allowed you to get directions
and taking notes and setting
alarms.  That was the precursor
to today's Google Assistant.
Gingerbread was the first
mainstream version of Android.
With Honeycomb, we added support
for tablets with the hollow
theme.  But, now we had a
problem because phones were
shipping on Gingerbread and
tablets were shipping on
Honeycomb.  So we
merged both with Ice Cream
Sandwich and we introduced more
intuitive navigation with the
use of gestures and that release
saw the arrial quick settings.
Jellybean included
project butter.  And smooth
animations are something that I
personally
ubzesabout.
Android Kit Kat came with
project with 512 megabytes and
DSP off-loaded Google Hot word.
Android 5 Lollipop followed and
was the mother of all releases.
It brought material design to
Android, giving it an entirely
new look and feel and so between
Project Butter and design, we
changed the narrative, giving it
a beautiful refined.
Lollipop also introduced
support for new categories for
wearables, auto and TV.  There
was the work profile, which
we've been building on.
Lollipop was such an epic
release that we frankly needed
to spend our energy in Android 6
Marshmallow on improving
quality.  We made an overhaul of
privacy with the introduction of
runtime permissions.
Nougat brought virtual support.
Oreo had entry-level smartphones
and came with a massive overhaul
of the hardware interface layer
to help speed up and reduce the
cost of doing upgrades.
Finally this year, we launched
Android Pie, which is an
AI-first experience.  It
contains tons of UI improvements
and introduces the concept of
well-being.
I think it's pretty incredible
to see just how far we have all
come in a decade of smartphone
development.  And while we're
solving different problems
today, it's clear the principles
upon which we built Android are
just as true today as they were
10 years ago.  Giving developers
a powerful SDK or open source
code to enable device makers
from entry level to high-end and
ever-improving UX.
So, what is the next 10 have in
store for Android?  Well, I
obviously don't have a crystal
ball, but there are three trends
that I want to call out that I
think are important.  One,
smartphones are getting smarter.
Two, multi-screen computing is
becoming pervasive and our
phones are going to be able to
help us with safety and digital
well-being.
Our smartphones are getting
smarter.  AI will enable your
phone to get to know you better.
You can see this in Android Pie
running on Google Pixel.  The
screen brightness automatically
learns your preferences and in
next apps are predicted to save
you time.  And the camera is
able to recognize objects in
realtime with Google Lens.
For developers wanting to tap
into AI, we announced ML Kit.
Whether you're new or
experienced
in machine learning, it has face
detection and more.
It builds on the neural networks
API by DSP and
NPUs.
API, boost performance,
MobileNet, for TensorFlow, runs
eight times faster using NNAPI
on the Qualcomm Snapdragon.  You
can expect NPUs to become faster
in the next few years.
The second trend goes beyond
phones.  We're investing heavily
in a multi-screen experience.
This means a great Android
experience across TVs,
wearables, cars and Chromebooks.
For example, user engagement on
Android TV is grown.  This year,
Android auto has seen 250% user
growth and our partners launched
9th watches.
Just when you thought you'd seen
everything in phones, we're
about to see a new idea.
Foldables.  They take advantage
of technology.  The screen can
literally bend and fold and you
can think of the device as both
a phone and a tablet.  And
broadly, two variants.  When
folded, it looks like a phone so
it fits in your pocket or purse
and the defining feature for
this form factor is something we
call, screen continuity.  You
might start a video on the
folded, smaller screen, but
later sit down and want a more
immersive experience.  You can
unfold the devis to get a larger
screen.  As you unfold, the app
transfers to the bigger screen
without missing a beat.
It's an exciting concept and we
expect to see foedable devices
from several Android
manufacturers.  We're working
with Samsung on a new device
they plan to launch early next
year, which you'll hear about
later today.
For our part, we're enhancing
Android to take advantage of
this new form factor, with as
little work as possible from
you.  We're adding resizable
flags so your app can respond to
folding and unfolding and we
expect to see a lot of
innovation over the next few
years.
The third trend is safety and
well-being.  Smartphones have
gone from non-existent to in
depensable.  In the very idea of
leaving your home without your
smartphone literally sends
shivers down people's spines.
Beyond utility, we FWEEL a
responsibility to your safety
and well-being.  More than 80%
of emergency calls originate
from mobile phones.  However,
locating these phones can be
challenging since technologies
fail indoors or have a radius
that's too large.
In a serious emergency, it can
mean the difference between life
and death.  We launched
Android's
Emergency Location Services.
When you dial 911 or your
country's equivalent, your
location is
accurately calculated and sent
directly to the emergency
provider.
ELS is built in to 99% of
Android phones, all there way
back to version 4 and we're
continuing to look at new ways
to improve your safety.
Now, having a smartphone with
you all day is awesome, but we
also want to make sure you're in
control of your digital
well-being and we know that 72%
of people are concerned with
amount of time they spend on
tech.
So with Android Pie this year,
we introduced new tools to let
you control usage with app
limits, gray scale wind-down and
Do Not Disturb.  Like most
features, we've added developer
hooks so you can tell if Do Not
Disturb is enabled and you can
implement an intent filter.
We're continuing to invest in
the space with lots of
enhancements planned.  Okay.
So, let's wrap-up.  Android,
from the beginning, was
conceived as a platform built
around developers.  We poured a
ton of energy into growing this
ecosystem from the ground up.
And in return, you've been an
amazing community building
incredible apps and services
that enable and delight users
the world over.  We simply could
not do this without you.  So,
thank you.
So with that, let's get down to
business.  I'm excited to hand
it over to Steph and team to
talk about the resent work we've
been doing.  Thank you.
[Applause]
>> Hey, everyone. I'm Steph.
I'm on the Android team and Dave
is right.  You're not on top of
it, you're a part of what we do.
Kotlin's a great example.  It's
not a Google-designed language.
It was not maybe the obvious
choice, but it was the best
choice, as you made clear.  We
could see developers voting with
their feet in the adoption and
the months before we announced
support.  Like Kotlin, our
developer investments come down
to two things at heart.
Number one, your feedback.  And
number two, Google engineers
using Android and thinking, how
do I make something people will
love?  So, the past several
years, we've been investing
deeply in Android's developer
experience.  It's been guided by
your feedback.  We're going to
talk about some new things that
we have to share.
So each year, we've been
investing.  Let's start with
ides.  We demoed Android Studio
at I/o.  Profilers, mobile
layout tools, better
R C++.  We wanted to add the
little things, whether that's
Maven integration to Lint
checks.
Second APIs.  In 2016, Diane
Hackborn wrote a famous post on
app architecture saying, we're
not opinionated.  To which she
repl replied, please be
opinionates.
[Laughter]
So we created architecture
components and refined them over
many EAPs and expanded them into
Android Jetpack.  We see Jetpack
as the future of our mobile
APIs.  They are opinionated and
easy to use, intuitive APIs that
work on 95% of devices.  We want
them to integrate seamlessly
with Android's core primitives
so you get the best possible
combination of efficiency and
deep control.
Expect to see us continue
expanding Jetpack every year.
Third was languages.  In 2017,
we announced support for Kotlin.
We've added since then, ide
support, API and moved it into
the Kotlin Foundation.
Fourth, app delivery.  So,
developers have always loved the
Play store, that's great when
you want to launch fast.  You
told us app size is way to big.
We announced the App Bundle and
Dynamic Delivery.  They are
sliming down apps worldwide with
most apps saving up to and over
30%.
Finally, security.  Android was
built with security in mind from
day one, with application
sandboxing.  We've expanded our
mobile security services.
Today, 99% of abusive apps are
taken down before anyone can
install and after you install,
we use Google Play to protect
and scan over 50 billion apps
every day.  Every app on every
connected device.  And we find a
potentially harmful app, we
disable it or we remove it.
Let's say you're doing
everything right and you
accidentally get caught in this
net without someone to talk to.
This is a place I think we need
to do better.  We need to make
it much easier for you to reach
us in these cases.  So, our
engineers will be here,
tomorrow, at the fireside chat,
to talk with you about it and
get your feedback.
Now another way we protect the
ecosystem is moving APIs to
target current APIs.  You told
us, okay, makes sense.  But
please give us a long notice
period so that's why we gave
almost a year's notice.  We
think of you as a part of how we
work, whether it's early ideas,
beta and iterating after launch.
We really want to be trustworthy
and we've heard about things you
love like Architecture Component
and Kotlin.  Sometimes we have
underestimated the time it takes
to get things right, like
instant run.  What we've heard
is you want from us open sharing
so you can see things that are
early, as long as we're clear.
As well as things that are ready
for production.
Today, I'm going to share a
range of early ideas.  I want to
walk you through two big themes.
First, foundations, using
languages and libraries to work
smarter.  Second, productivity.
Using mobile ides, console and
distribution to develop easier,
have higher quality apps and to
grow adoption.
We're going to start with
foundations and Kotlin.
Throughout, I wanted you to hear
from some of the people who have
been instrumental in these
projects.  So, we're going to
start with someone who was key
in the Kotlin decision, he's a
huge contributor to Android,
both while he was in the
community, now in the Google
team.  It's a privilege to turn
things over to Jake Wharton.
[Applause]
Hey, everyone.  So, I'm jake,
I'm part of the team working on
Kotlin for Android and it's been
18 months since Steph was on
stage at Google I/O announcing
Kotlin would be supported as a
new first-class language.
Something that had never been
done in the history of Android.
Based on positive feedback from
developers, it's clear that this
was the right choice.  According
to GitHub, Kotlin is the number
Worker fastest-growing language
in terms
of contributors.  Stack Overflow
places it as number two.
In Android, 46% of proAndroid
developers are using Kotlin to
build their apps.
This is according to a survey.
In October, we had 118, 000
seven-day active projects using
Kotlin in Android Studio.  This
is based on those who opt-in.
10 X increase from the numbers
last year.
Now when Kotlin support was
announced, there were a bunch of
apps that were using in the Play
store.  Includes WeChat, Amazon
Kindle and Twitter.  It moved
into the Kotlin Foundation and
we're fortunate to partner with
JetBrains.
Just last week, they released
the newest version of Kotlin,
1.3 with new language features,
APIs, bug fixes and performance
improvements.  For example,
in-line classes, which in most
cases, don't actually allocate
like a normal class would unless
they're boxed.  For constrained
devices that we target, avoiding
allocation while still
restraining typesafety is a big
one The Kotlin library includes
a set of numbers, such as UByte
and ULong.  And in addition to
Kotlin code targeting Android or
the JVM, you can target
JavaScript or native code.  This
unlocks the possibility of using
more on platforms The
long-awaited support is in 1.3,
which is a lighter version of
threading.  It combines how you
do operations.
Things that are essential to
every Android app.  And, as I'm
sure you are, we are looking
forward to using these new
Kotlin features in the
Kotlin-specific APIs.  The
majority has been through the
Kotlin extensions through
Jetpack.
We announced the Kotlin
extensions
were expanding to KTX.  And all
these are now available at
stable releases.
Since then, though, as new APIs
are added to existing libraries
or new libraries, the KTX
extensions are being built
alongside, navigation, paging,
Slices have extensions being
built with them.
We're starting to go beyond,
lifecycle is going to let you
launch it and have
cancellations.  WorkManager with
a work object based on
Coroutine.  They provide more
close operability.
If you want to get started with,
say, Coroutines on Android,
there's a new codelab, it covers
work, testing of Coroutines.
Since Kotlin isn't a language
for building Android apps,
Google cloud platforms has it.
And finally, new udacity courses
are available today.  They use
both Jetpack and popular
third-party libraries To speak
more about Jetpack as a whole,
I'd like to turn it over to
Romain Guy.
[Applause]
>> Hi, I work on the Android
framework team.  A few months
ago, we announced Jetpack.  It
builds on the foundation that we
laid out with support library.
We also added new tools and
libraries to the mix.  It is
about less
code and more devices.  All
Jetpack libraries are backwards
compatible.  We first started
running early access programs
about two years ago and then our
first one was 18 months ago at
Google I/O 2017.  Out of
the top 1,000 applications, more
are using it.
Jetpack is using New York Times,
EverNote, Pandora, Twitter and
many more.  Apps built all over
the world in India, Germany,
France, Korea, Israel, China,
U.S. And more.
Also, at I/O, we have new
libraries for paging,
navigation, WorkManager and
Slices.  These are in early
faces of development, they're
being used in 38,000
applications worldwide.
We know that many of you have
expressed the desire than simply
give feedback.  We moved it all
to public.  You can see bug
fixes and features in realtime.
All you need is Android Studio
and a public SDK.  We also want
to use AOSP.  Our hope to
earlier access will help us
refine and ship even better
libraries.  So, please join us.
With Jetpack, we introduced
Architecture Component
libraries, navigation and
WorkManager.  There is a
simplified way to have the
principles in the application
using a single activity.  You
have consistent animations and
easier animated transitions.
WorkManager makes it easy to
perform background tasks.  You
do not need to whether you
should be using Job Scheduler,
JobDispatcher or alarmmanager.
If you have any feedback about
those APIs, the Android teams
are here today and tomorrow, so
now is the time to give us that
feedback.
We introduced Android Slices, a
new way to bring users to your
applications.  It is a mini
snippet.  It can help users book
a flight, call a ride and so on.
We want to take the time to get
things right.  After working
with several of you on the APIs,
we're moving into public EAP at
the end of the month.  We will
run experiments surfacing Slices
in Google results.
Our team has been hard at work
bringing numerous improvements
to libraries.  In 2.1, you have
more control over usage.  2.1 is
our biggest launch since 1.0.
We have search tables and
integration.
3.2 brings most faster
multi-module.
One thing you told us worked
pretty well was
deeply-integrated tools and
libraries.  A new great example
is navigation.  You can
easily-understand and build it
in your application.
Let's go straight to a demo.
Here, it was already partially
done.  You can see the flow of
navigation.  If I run the demo
in the emulator, and we wait for
Gradle to do its job, I can
click on leaderboards and see
different profiles.  If I click
on the profile, nothing happens.
I can go back to the editor, add
a new screen, select the
fragment to the user profiles
and then the link -- the
leaderboard screen to the user
profile.  I also need to add an
argument for the selected user.
And it's a string.  And just
rerun the app.  Wait for Gradle.
Want to chat with me after this?
[Laughter]
If I click on the profile, now I
can see the profile.  You can
see there are no animations, no
transitions.  So if I go back
and select this navigation no
flow, I can choose which
animations I want.  I'm going to
choose the intro animations and
the exit animations.  And now,
if I rerun the app, one last
time, go back to leaderboards
and now you can see the
transition.
So if you want to play with --
[Applause]
So, in you want to play with
animation, all you have to do is
download Android Studio from
beta today.
As we expand the Jetpack
libraries, we're focused on your
feedback.  So please let us
know.  We want to know about
animations, UI, we are here
today.  We are here tomorrow.
With that, I would like to turn
it over to Karen, who will let
you know about our plans.
Thanks.
[Applause]
>> Hi. I'm Karen. I'm on the
team that builds Android Studio
and Android Jetpack.  To build
on top of that, I'm going to
talk about productivity.  For
3.2, we asked ourselves, what
can we do to have a meaningful
impact on productivity and where
do you spend the most of your
time.  We heard it's build
speed.  Something you do every
day.  Something you do every
day, multiple times a day and
every time you're waiting for
that build to finish, we know
it's a minute wasted.  We found
two things to be true, the first
thing we found is that build
speeds is actually getting
slower over time.  The second
thing we found is that new
releases of Studio are actually
improving build times.  We saw
build speeds get faster by 42%.
Something's going on and we had
to take a deeper look.
Codebases are getting larger,
custom build-ins are adding to
times are negating the benefit
of incremental builds.  If you
have many modules, research
management can add time, as
well.  It is outgrowing our
build improvements.  We are
committed to making build
faster.  A large part of the
time, on build here, this week,
you can listen and learn more
about what we're doing.  We want
to get this right and we need
your help to do it.  We're
giving ourselves goals and
working on attribution tools to
better-understand what's
affecting your build in your
projects and we're making Gradle
faster.
We know that speed is better.
It's about trying things out,
iterating and failing fast and
doing it again.  With instant
run, we want to quickly apply
changes.  Part of that is around
deployment times. We know they
play a huge part and we've
shipped an update in Android Pie
where we're seeing a big
difference in real-world and
sample projects between Pie and
Oreo.  If you're using USB, we
have seen close to that emulator
speed.  Please let us know if
you're interested in giving
early feedback.
That takes us to emulators.
Because we want to make
iteration speed faster, we're
investing in emulators for every
OS.  We show you a snapshot and
boot up and switch in under two
seconds.
Productivity is also about
making the hard problems easier.
We heard it's hard to know how
you app is affecting battery
life.  You can visualize the
battery usage and inspect
background events.
The new beta for Android Studio
3.3 is available today and was
just released moments ago.
We know that in order for it to
be delightful, it has to be not
just stable, but it has to be
rock-solid stable because of the
number of hours that you spend
there.  The main focus for our
next few releases will be
quality, which we're calling
Project Marble.  Fixing user
impacting bugs and investing our
infrastructure and tools.  We
know that sometimes we've missed
memory leaks before we've
shipped so we're building tools
to help protect those leaks
before they even happen.
Dave mentioned how millions of
Android apps run on chromebooks,
we're bringing it to Chrome OS
later next year.
Now, I'd like to invite Matt
Henderson to share more about
app size and what we're doing
with the Android App Bundle.
[Applause]
So, I work on developer tools,
like the Play console.  Apps
have grown dramatically in size.
The average is up five times
since 2012.  But larger size
carries a cost.  It reduces the
install conversion rate and it
increases uninstall rate.  You
told us that using multi-APK was
a painful way to reduce app
size.  So the Android App Bundle
makes it much simpler.  Using
the App Bundle, we reduce size
by generating an APK for the
languages, the screen density,
the CPU architecture that each
user needs.  And it's working.
While size reductions vary, on
average, apps are seeing a 35%
reduction in size compared to a
universal APK.
Now, with the recent stable
release of Android Studio 3.2,
App Bundles and production have
taken off.  They're up ten
times.  Thousands of developers
have embraced App Bundle and the
number in production total
billions of installs.  And
Google's apps, they're
switching, too.  YouTube, Google
Maps, photos, Google News are
all in production.  Photos, for
example, is now 40% smaller.
So, we're really excited about
the App Bundle's potential.  We
sign APK for delivery to the end
user.  This is highly-secure.
We protect your key in the same
memory that -- in the same
storage we protect Google's own
keys.  It allows us to process
the App Bundle to generate the
optimized APKs and this allows
you to benefit from additional
optimizations in the future.
Starting right now, so I'm happy
to announce that the App Bundle
now supports uncompressed native
libraries.  This utilizes an
existing Android platform
feature that was little used
because in the past, you would
have had to use devices.  We
have no additional developer
work needed.  The App Bundle now
makes apps
using native libraries 8%
smaller to download.
By adding dynamic features, you
can add any app functionality
on-demand.  For example, you
don't need to send that same big
feature to 100% of your users if
it's only going to be used by
10% of them.  And you don't need
to keep big features that are
only used once.  Dynamic
features can be installed and
uninstalled dynamically when
your app requests it.
Or, you can chose to defer
installing to a later time, when
the app goes to the background.
Facebook was one of our launch
partners.  And they are using
dynamic features in production
in the main Facebook app and in
Facebook Lite.  For example,
card scanning is a feature that
only a small percentage of
Facebook's user base is using so
moving it to a dynamic feature
avoids it taking up almost two
megabytes on each user's device
Within an App Bundle, installed
and instant apps can have the
same base module and the same
dynamic feature modules.
Separating it out is a great way
to get your base small enough to
offer an instant app experience.
Now, you can start building and
testing dynamic features using
Android Studio 3.2 today and
join our beta Now, I'd like to
invite
you up to talk more.
>> Thanks, Matt. We've heard
your feedback, that you'd like
to more control to ensure users
are running the latest and
greatest version of your app.
There's the Google Play update
API.  There's an immediate
update flow where they have a
full-screen experience, they can
accept the update and have it
installed immediately.  Many of
you have implemented similar
variance in your app.  This new
implementation is less
error-prone and super easy to
integrate.
Next is flexible updates.
Flexible updates are really cool
because they actually allow the
update experience to be
integrated into your app.  As an
example, Google Chrome nudges
users.  If the user accepts that
update, the download happens in
the background and the user can
continue to use your app.  When
the download is complete, it's
up to you, as the developer, to
decide if you'd like the update
to be applied immediately or if
you'd like it applied the next
time the app is in the
background.  Google Chrome is
testing this now and we're
excited to be testing access
coming soon.
Next instant apps.  Instants
apps are avail on 1.3 billion
devices.  We've been hard at
work on simplifying the
development experience for
instant apps.  Earlier this
year, we increased the size
limit for instant apps from 4
megabytes to 10 megabytes.  Many
developers are already able to
get under that size limit
without additional work.
Additionally, the dynamic
features are instant compatible.
We've also made it possible to
upload and test intent apps of
any size.  You canexperience
iterate on the user  at the same
time you're optimizing for size.
And we've also made
web URLs.
You can reroute your users into
your instant experience
automatically.
Lastly, I'm excited to announce
that today, in Android Studio
3.3 beta, you can now have a
single Android Studio that
houses your instant and
installed apps.  This
dramatically helps.
Additionally, the App Bundle can
be uploaded once to the Play
developer console.
We're super excited about that.
And, with that, back to
Steph.
[Applause]
>> Android's open source means
it's an incredible to watch what
you're building on top of the
platform.  With over 2 billion
devices, three-quarters of [no
audio]
audio].
So, that's it for the keynote.
Thank you.  I hope you enjoy
Android Dev Summit.
[Applause]
>> Now, everyone, please give a
warm welcome to Dan
Galpin.
[Applause]
[Loss of
I first wanted to give a
shout-out to everyone on the
livestream, I hope you could all
be here in person.  You can also
follow the online action on
Twitter.
And now, I need my next slide.
[Laughter]
Otherwise, I'll have to
improvise.  I can do this.  So,
there's a lot of stuff going on
here, today.  One of the things
I want all of you, onsite, to be
able to take advantage of is the
fact that we have a tremendous
amount of Android experts
available here in office hours.
It will be out in the lobbies,
next to these rooms.  Whether
you're here or tuning in
remotely, check out the Android
Dev Summit app so you can look
at all the events and build your
own schedule.
Now you'll notice we have
different sections throughout
the day.  This is a bit of an
experiment and the 20-minute
sessions are going to run
back-to-back with the intention
that you watch both sessions
because there's no time to leave
the room.  Also, we have
lightning talks that are going
to be a speed round where we
move as quickly aspossible to
smash as much content to 40
minutes.
We're going to have Q&A with the
presenters, outside of these.
Make sure to check out the
schedule posted on the wall.  We
have so many that wanted to talk
to you that we actually can't
fit them here at all once.  You
want to make sure that you're
here so that the engineer that
worked on bugs that you might be
interested are actually going to
be there to defend themselves.
LAEF  [Laughter]
Office hours will be running all
day so you're allowed to skip
class if you want to go to
office hours.  And decides,
we're going to be running all
the these.
We have having a party later on.
Get ready for an epic night of
music and standing around and
talking to people.
[Laughter]
And that's it.  I really
appreciate everything.  We have
a little break now and so enjoy
the rest of
Android Dev Summit [Applause]
Everyone, our next session will
begin in 10 minutes.
Welcome, everyone.  Welcome
back.  Our program is going to
be underway in three minutes.
We ask that you mute your mobile
devices and thank you for taking
your seats.
Our program will begin in three
minutes.
I haven't done anything yet.
Thanks for coming.  My name is
Jose Alcrreca.
My name is Yigit Boyar.  I'm an
engineer.
Today, we're going to talk about
LiveData.  LiveData is one of
the first Architecture Component
that we've released last year
and in this talk, we're going to
explain what it is.  We're going
to talk about some of the
transformations you can do, how
to come been LiveDatas and talk
about patterns and anti-patterns
you might want to avoid.
We're going to explain all these
characteristics, but first,
we're going to start with
observable, what's an
observable?  So, in our
object-oriented world, probably
the easiest way of communicated
one component and another is
having a reference from one
object from another and call it
directly.
However, in Android, this might
have problems.  Components have
different likecycles and
different lifespans.  This is
the ViewModel scope diagram.
Simple thing like device
rotation can re-create the
activity.  So, you probably know
that having a reference of
activity in this ViewModel would
be a bad idea because it leads
to memory leaks, even crashes
with no exceptions.
So, instead of having a
reference AKactivity, we're
going to have in the activity.
How to we send data?  We're
going to let the activity
observe the ViewModel.  And for
that, we're going to use
observables LiveData.
Let's see how this looks with a
little bit of code.  In the
ViewModel, we expose our
LiveData.  You're going to see a
little examples of how to expose
LiveData from our ViewModel.  In
our activity, we make the actual
subscription and we do that by
calling the observe method.  The
first parameter is something
called likecycle.  Yigit is
going to talk about this.
The second part is an
observeable.  This is what's
called whenever the observable,
the LiveData's value is changed.
So, Jose mentioned you want to
reference an object in the
larger scope, like a ViewModel
from an object in a smaller
scope, like an activity.  But of
course when you observe
something, it has to keep a
reference back to you to be able
to call it so there is a
reference.  But why is this not
a problem with LiveData?  It is
a component.  To be able to
observe LiveData, you have to
provide the lifecycle and it
maintains your subscription for
free.  So, if you're observer's
lifecycle is not in a good
state, it's not going to call
you back.  Or when your activity
or fragment is destroyed, it
will call it back for you.
If you go back to the previous
graph, your LiveData observer
will only be called when it is
started and before it starts.
You don't need to care about
fragment.
Probably the most, like,
distinctive property of LiveData
is the data holder.  It's not --
we keep saying this, it's not a
stream, it's a value holder.  If
you go back to our previous
graphs, on the right, we have
LiveData in ViewModel and on the
left is activity or fragment
observing this.  Once you set
the LiveData, it is passed to
the activity.  When it changes,
the activity receives a new
updated value.
The difference happens when you
change the value when
observeable is not in an active
state, it has no idea that it is
the activity.  While your
activity's still in the
background, you send a new value
and your activity still doesn't
see this.
Now, the data holder property
comes in now when your activity
comes back, what user is seeing
in the foreground.  It receives
the latest value from the
ViewModel.  It only cares about
holding a single value and it's
the latest value.  This works
perfect for UI because you only
want to show what it is right
now.  But, if you are trying to
process this, this is not what
you're looking for.
Similarly, if you change the
value after activity is
destroyed, nothing happens.
Okay.  Let's talk about
LiveData.  The libraries
provides map.  We already said
that LiveData's great to
communicate view and a
ViewModel.  What if we have a
third component, maybe a
deposit?  How do we make this
from the ViewModel?  We don't
have a lifecycle there.  What if
it is observing data sources, in
this case?  Well, Yigit said to
me, if you need a lifecycle in
your ViewModel, you probably
need a transformation, but
that's actually wrong.
[Laughter]
Sorry, Yigit.  What I say is
that you definitely need a
transformation.  Don't eve R use
lifecycle.
So, how do we make a bridge
between the view and
this?  We use a map.  A
one-to-one static
transformation.  We use
LiveData, ViewModel result.
It's the result of a
transformation's map.  The first
parameter is the source, the
LiveData source and the second
parameter is the transformation
function.  It's converting from
the data of the model to the UI
model.  This is how the
signature would look like in
Kotlin.  It has source, which is
a LiveData of X and it returns a
LiveData y.  So, it's a breach
of LiveDatas and in the middle,
we have a transformation
function that transtorms from X
to Y.  It doesn't know anything
about LiveData.
So, when you establish the
transformation, the key, here,
is the lifecycle is carried over
for you.  Let's say you run a
transformation of a couple of
LiveData and you hold on to it.
When someone -- that lifecycle
is propagated to the LiveData
elements without you doing
anything and it's completely
managed by us, so it's
completely safe.
We have switchMaps. You have an
application I you have a user
measure that keeps the log user
ID.  When you grab it, you need
to talk to your user to get the
user object and that probably
goes to the database and to the
server.  It turns the LiveData,
as well.  Because user object
might change, right?  It might
return you the cache.  So you're
in this situation where you have
LiveData and a LiveData for user
and you need to chain these
things.  So networks, if you are
chaining from an ID to a user,
how do we change from
an ID, that's switchMap.
We provided LiveData and our
function, this time, returns the
LiveData.  So, signature looks
like this.  You have a source.
At the end, you have a LiveData
and you provide a function that
converts the X to LiveData.
What this technically does is
every time the user ID changes,
it calls your function.  You
give it a new LiveData, it takes
it from in previous data and
that is the new one.  Like
switches tracks or like
switchboards.
It's completely managed for you.
You get all the benefits of
using LiveData.
Now, we only provide Map and
switchMap.  You don't have a
million transformations.  This
is very limiting and sometimes
you may want to write you own
and we don't want to provide
many.  If you want to write your
own, it's very easy.  If I show
you the little code we have for
the mapping implementation, it
returns the LiveData and you
give it a function, right.  All
it does is creates this
MediatorLiveData and it is a
source for the MediatorLiveData.
It kind of tells us that the
value of this MediatorLiveData
is derived from this other
LiveData.  So whenever that
other LiveData changes, call my
call-back and in the call-back,
we apply the function to the
value and set the value on the
MediatorLiveData.  This is super
simple to write.  And there is
no lifecycle here, but all of
this code is lifecycle.
So, if it's so easy, let's
create a new one.  Let's say we
want to do a bunch of strings
and you want to have the total.
LiveData and another LiveData
and you have a LiveData that has
the total number of characters
in those elements and it updates
if any of those values update.
So, we call the total line.  We
receive a list of LiveDatas and
we return the LiveData.  What we
do, here, is we have a function.
It is very simple.  It goes
through all of the LiveDatas and
sums their length.  We need to
account for nulls here because
LiveData has nulls.  Look at all
the LiveData values and the
total length.  Once we did that,
we add each given LiveData as a
source to our mediator.  It says
the value of this mediator
depends on this other LiveData.
Any time it changes, it calls
back our function, which
calculates the new value for the
MediatorLiveData.
And this is, like, four lines of
code and you have a
transformation of your
LiveDatas.
Now, there are some common
mistakes you can make while
using LiveData and we want to
touch base on these things.  One
thing we see a lot is, let's say
you -- you use JSON,
using transformation for that is
not a good idea because it is a
value holder.  The long string
you fetch from your server is
going to stay in memory.  It's
going to hold on to that so you
probably don't want to use
LiveData for something like
that.
Okay.  The second item is
about sharing instances of
LiveData.  At one point, I was
trying to make an app with
LiveDatas and I had a repository
that was there.  I said, okay, I
can just save some LiveDatas and
share a single LiveData.  I a
repository, it takes a data
source and the LiveData we're
returning in load item is shared
by everyone that calls load
item.
Now, this is fine, it works.
But this a very interesting
case.  This anti pattern is
about you thinking about which
servers are going to be active.
There is this case, in Android,
where two activities are going
to be active at the same time.
Imagine activity 1 observes item
number 1 and activity number two
observes number two.  When we
load activity 2, it's going to
load data for item 2.  Activity
one is also going to receive
that data.  Because it's in the
middle of the animation, you're
going to see a flash, a glitch.
You created a field that's an
instance of LiveData, you're
probably doing it wrong.
The solution is to create a
LiveData every time.  It's very
light-weight.
The third item is about where
and when to create your
transformations and this is all
about wiring.  It's similar to
when you create a circuit.  You
lay down your components and you
wire everything up and for one
set of inputs, you're going to
have a known set of outputs.
But you don't unplug a wire when
it's in operation and plug it in
somewhere else.  This is exactly
what this ViewModel is doing.
Lots of horrible things
happening in this ViewModel, by
the way.
[Laughter]
For starters --
You should have a, don't do
this, in this slide.
[Laughter]
Someone copy-pasted and then
blamed us.
[Laughter]
It's exposing item data, which
is a valuable.  And also, it's
exposing a mutable LiveData.
You should almost never do this.
You should always expose
something that is immutable so
your observers can't change it.
So, after subscription, we call
load data from our activity to
set the ID of the thing we want
to load and we reassigning item
data to something.  Something
happened, so the observer is not
going to know --
Actually, even if you're
returning LiveData and your
observe observer's subscribing,
they're doing the new one.
So, the solution to this
requires a little bit of
planning.  We have two
LiveDatas.  One is mutable and
it's private to this ViewModel.
And the other one is the one
that is exposed from the
ViewModel.  The is
transformation source map.  It
is that mutable LiveData so
every time that item ID changes,
the transformation is going to
be called with the appropriate
ID.
After the subscription to this
item data has happened, we call
load data, we pass the string,
it might come from the intent
and when we set the value, it
triggers an update and
everything is going to work as
you expected it to work.
Okay.  So, we like to think
LiveData is awesome and is
solves all the problems, but it
doesn't.  We see people trying
to use it in other areas.  I
want to make it clear, if you're
writing an application for
operators, you totally bought
into this, use RxJava.
If you have things that are not
related to lifecycle or UI, you
are trying to synchronize it to
the the back-end, there's no
reason to use LiveData for
something like that.  Use a
call-back.
Another use case is having these
operations, you have data and
convert it and log back and
return it.  For those things, if
you are using Kotlin, it is a
new, exciting area.  You might
use RxJava, but don't use
LiveData.  LiveData works very
well as the last layer for your
UI.  It's perfectly okay.  If
you try to scale it, it's just
not going to work.
So, many things we mentioned in
this talk -- actually Jose has
more.  You can go read them.
Check out our samples on GitHub.
We have simple uses of LiveData,
as well as complicated with
using Room.  Has multiple data
sources, transformations and you
can look at the code.  If it has
bugs, you can blame this guy.
He wrote it.
Yeah.  Thank you very much for
coming.  I hope this was useful
and we will be in -- after the
talks.
Thank you.
[Applause]
Okay.
We will start.  Sorry.
This guy's new, who are you?
[Laughter]
I'm Daniel Santiago.  I work
mainly in Room.
Okay.  So, today, we are going
to talk about Room.  But, before
we -- I don't think my clicker's
working.  Nope.
Working on it, guys.
Okay.  Sorry.  All right.
Yes, it started working.  Now
I'm trying to go back.  Okay.
Now -- yes.  All cool.
So, why do you want Room or do
you want to write Room?  We
asked people to write
offline-ready applications
[no audioaudio].
It's pretty much impossible.  So
for this reason, you do need a
database.  We have esculite.
It's very fast and when you need
to optimize it for your use
case, it's very easy to do so.
It's a really powerful query
language.  You can express many
things and make
it concise.
And SQLite scales very well.
For an application, you probably
won't have much data, but you
can have multiple gigabytes.
For your
scalables, SQLite would be
perfect.
You need to write out of
boilerplate to convert between
your Java and your SQLite.
There's no compile time safety
so if you're building a query
and you forget an "if "case,
you're going to get a runtime
crash.
You cannot observe what has
changed.  We want people to
write reactive applications or
UIs and if you can't observe, it
is hard.  You have to build it
yourself.  So, we build it for
you.  So, about two years ago,
we ship Room, we introduce
compile time safety and a strong
ID integration. As you can
notice with Room, with
navigations, this is a big thing
for us.  We want to develop
librarlibraries, together with
Android Studio.
This year's I/O, we had SQLite
and support for paging so you
can have data sets, queries and
log them.
The release is a conversion from
Android support to AndroidX.  We
kept it the same as 1.1 so you
can have an easy migration.
2.1, we're going to talk about
today.  This is 2.0.  We have,
like, full text search, wheels,
AutoValue and more stuff.
One of the pretty cool new
feature s we added in 2.1 is
full-textsearch.  It's a way to
index text documents and make
them searchable.  Let's take a
look at an example.  Imagine we
have a music app and we want to
search function.  You want to
type something, you want to be
able to find songs within that
music app.  If we have Room, we
expression, we store this song
data in a table that's an
entity.  Conveniently, we have
our label objects and our song
labels, you know, what's the
song name, label name and artist
name, this is kind of what we
want to search and make the
index.
If we were to do this, we need
to write a query and you had to
use the operator.  This is not
very good.  It's very limited.
That percentage sign is kind of
like a wild card and this --
Even if you index that query
column, SQLite won't be able to
use it.
So, don't do this.  Moreover, if
you try to actually search
across, you have to expand this
query.  And this, as you can
see, doesn't easily scale.
They helped us with this
situation because it now creates
a table and all the columns are
-- you now want to take your
entity.
Now, in your query, you use a
different operator and we were
seeing the same column and that
basically tells the mash
operator that you want to search
across all those labels so this
helps us with searching.
You might say, oh, I can use
this on all of my tables, but
not quite.  It consumes more
space because when you create a
table, you create a table and
that's back by a few tables and
a lot of the information. This
is known as chatter tables, when
you query from your table, the
information comes from these
tables.
There's also a few things.  You
cannot have keys or compose
primary keys. But there's one
pretty neat
feature, which is external
content and going back to this,
if we wanted to use our real
table and create a second table
for only our labels, we just
basically use that annotation,
but we told it, hey, my data is
actually going to be storing
this other table that I already
have.
Conveniently, this data class
and virtual table has labels.
In the previous one, even the
URL is not what we wanted to
index.
What happens now is we have a
table in front of it and behind
it, we have the same shadow
tables for indexes but the
actual content we store in the
table we have.  This is way
better in saving space and it's
a little bit more flexible.
To query this external table,
you do have to query from the
virtual table and then you would
do a join because we want to get
the songs and similarly, you
would still use match.
One thing, though, is that
because these are two different
tables, when you insert into the
sound tables, things are not
actually inserted, which means
it doesn't get updated so you
have to do that yourself.  But
you know, we don't want you
doing this.  We want to make it
easy.  When you use Room, it
will create trigger for you to
keep these two things in sync,
that's pretty cool.
Another important feature is
support for database views.  We
have songs and albums and a song
might be in multiple albums so
we have a junction table that
associates the songs.  Now, this
is all cool.  You want to fetch
a listing and have the album
name and all the songs in it as
a list.  Okay, cool.  We have
the list and we write a query
and fetch from that junction
table.  You cannot do this
because that table doesn't have
the song's name or the album's
title.  You kind of need to
write a query like this where
you fetch from the table and
join it with the song and table
and then you can return your
list and data.
SQLite is powerful that you can
express this, if you find
yourself writing these things,
it is like a boilerplate.  It
could be cool if you could have
a table that has the song and
the album together, without
duplicating the data into that
data and the songs and the album
titles.  This is where database
views come into place.  You
basically write the query that
defines album and song together
as a query.  You annotate an
entity with that database view.
And in that, this is the same
Room.  You can have any with the
fields or whatnot.
Once you declare it, add it to
your Room database -- so we have
that declaration, if you try to
rewrite the previous query, you
select from that table.  Well,
we are selected from a view,
that table doesn't exist.  But
for all intents and purposes of
querying, that's a table.  Now
it's much more simpler because
it's like a table.  You can also
return or even return the live
data because we know how that is
constructed, we know when it
might change so you can get the
LiveData and run queries.  You
can do everything you can do
with a table, except you cannot
do inserts and updates.  But you
can have views inside other
views.
So, this makes it much nicer to
write queries and allows you to
logically address your data.
Another important feature we
have added is support for
multiple instances.  So, let's
say we are writing the
applications, we have a play
list, all the songs and we have
a sync service that goes and
pulls the names, updates from my
play list.  When you're using
Room, if the sync service
updates the database, it
automatically updates the UI and
this is a super cool feature
because you write these.  This
works perfectly,
but then your application is
bloated so you decide to go into
background posses.
It pulls the song, writes into
the database and the UI has no
idea.  It doesn't know the
database has changed because it
only knows if the same Room.  We
don't get that information from
SQLite.
Now, with Room 2.1, you can in
build multiinstances which will
look for other instances of
Room.  Once you do that, now
your background process service
can update the database and all
this in Room will update
automatically.  Now, this is all
by default because we need to
create the server s.  It is a
cost that most people don't
need.  We enabled this flag to
take advantage of this feature.
Another feature we added,
which was actually requested by
the community, was added value
support.  If you're using
Kotlin, you don't have to worry
about this because you have data
classes.  If not, you might be
using other values.  Room can
understand these AutoValue
annotated objects.  If you know
a little bit about value, you
have an abstract class and you
annotate it with other values.
Now you can annotate that same
abstract value and Room will be
able to discover you want to
make a table for it.
These can now be annotated with
Room annotations through the key
column information and things
like that.
The only caveat is that you have
to add AutoValue computation and
this is the annotation that
makes these two tools work
together.
To support this, normally
these annotations were only
limited to fields and we needed
to extend it to let you put them
on those abstract methods but it
only works if you're using
AutoValue.
Similarly, if you were using a
normal class, you would would
have fields.  You still need
that factory method and Room
will be able to discover this.
You would use the abstract class
that you would declare.
Another highly-requested feature
that has been requested for
awhile is this.  You can have a
sync return times and insert,
update and delete.  We listen.
When you request, we'll listen.
[Laughter]
This is actually -- this is only
available in rx, that's
interesting.
It might
be available --
So Room 2.1 is a really big
release, the full-text search,
the database views.  When we
decided which features to work
on, we were basically relying on
your
feedback.  People really wanted
it.  This is our philosophy, we
look at what the community is
doing, how are they using it,
what do they want and implement
it.  So, please, like, try to
use 2.1.  It's a very big
release and we want to ship it
as stable as soon as possible
and we need your feedback.
We look at in number of apps
shipping through them and see
how they are using.  We look for
the incoming box -- we don't
really have box, but sometimes.
Look for incoming user error.
[Laughter]
To fix them.
So, please work with us and
we'll try to wrap it up and ship
it and also, please let us know
what other features you want in
Room All right.  Thanks a lot
for coming to this talk.  I hope
it was useful.
[Applause]
Thank you.
We will be in the sandbox
area, after the talk.
Thank you.
Everyone, our next session, in
this room, will begin in 10
minutes.  Thanks.
Welcome, everyone.  Welcome
back.  Our next session will get
underway in about two minutes.
As a courtesy to our presenters,
we ask you to mute your devices.
We'll get under way in about two
minutes.
Hey, everyone, welcome to our
lightning round and this is
where we try to smash an in
credible amount of content into
This is going to be40 minutes.
really, really fun.  We have an
incredibly-distinguished set of
speakers and I'm going to talk
really fast.  If you hear a
gong, that means somebody has
gone over.  We are going to try
to move this really, really
quickly.
Our first talk is going to be
about JNI.  Please welcome
Elliot Hughes.
[Applause]
My name's Elliot Hughes.  I've
working for Android for awhile.
My first job on Android was
working on the JNI libraries and
cleaning up some of the bugs.
First off, I'll show you what
you're expecting to see when you
see JNI, which is code that
looks like this.  I'm guessing
no one can tell that the code
that does anything useful isn't
on that screen yet.  And I'm
guessing no one can tell me
where the useful line is in
that, either.
This talk is how to not do that.
How do we get away from that?
The one-line answer is, use C++
better.  If you're using the
CAPIs, it is tricky.  You end up
with a nesting style.  There are
a lot of special cases, like,
I'm trying to throw an
exception, but there's already
an exception pending.
So, don't write that in every
single JNI method.  Write that
once.  And in particular, have
classes that let you use a
string as a string.  You know,
use a J string as if it's a
string.  Similar for a raise.
You don't want to do with a J
when you can use operator square
brackets.
Local references, too.  The
strings and rimative arrays are
most of them.  Exceptions,
harder than they look and the --
the sort of raw primitives you
get in JNI are not super useful.
They expect you to find the
class yourself and create an
instance.  If you want to
actually include a proper detail
message or a cause, you end up
doing weird things like, I need
to find the constructer for
this.  Blah, blah, blah.  It's a
lot of code, especially if you
deal with special cases.  Having
a function that takes a format
string is a huge relief and --
right.
I've been talking about this in
the abstract saying, you should
use these things.  There are
many choices and I think a
problem a lot of people have is
they get hung up on what's the
best way to do this?  Any of
these are better than writing
the code that we saw.  Android
uses a native helper.  It has
things to do the stuff I've been
talking about.  If you don't
like any of the others on the
internet, you can write your
own.
So, what does it look like if
you switch to using something
like this?  This is the same
code.  This is the same two
slides we had before, now
condensed into one.  I think
five seconds is enough time to
see what does the work here.
You don't need to have the style
where we have the constructers
and we check, did that actually
work?  If we're prepared to use
C++ exceptions, that is more
advanced.  This gets you 90% of
the benefit with 20% of the
effort.  This is what the code
looks like in Android for that
call.
So, that was a really simple
thing, where there really was
just one line of active
ingredient in there, but this
scales really well.  Our
recommendation is you try to
keep your code like that.  Don't
mix all the JNI boilerplate
stuff.  On the other end, you
wouldn't mix your business logic
and UI rendering stuff.  It 's
similar advice, don't do that.
If you want a good example of
this, the Android system OS
class is implementing exactly
this same way.  It's super
repetitive, really boring and
that's the way we like it.
If you need to worry about old
Android releases and you have
multiple SO files, that can get
tricky.  We recommend you go to
GitHub.  The files on compress,
that was mentioned earlier in
the keynote.  One, big library
is generally bigger than lots of
small libraries.
Thank you.  If you have
questions, please come find me.
I'll be doing open house all
afternoon.  Thank you.
[Applause]
I wanted to share with you a
short story about my experience
with the Kotlin multiplatform
project.  When we come and talk
about Android and Kotlin, what
we really mean is Kotlin JVM,
that's the Kotlin that we know
that gets confiled to Java
bytecode and we can transform it
and run it on Android.  It can
run on cloud servers and our
desktops and so on.
There are two more flavors of
Kotlin, JVM.
And then there's Kotlin/Native
that can run or target various
platforms, even web assembly and
even Android.
How would we actually get
started with this.  Kotlin 1.3
has a new structure.  If you
apply that, you can then select
from a set of presets to target
any of these platforms.  Here,
I'm targeting an Android library
and a JS target.  When you add
these to your module, it
automatically creates source
sets for these Kotlin files.  If
you put your Kotlin files in the
JS main folder, they will get
compiled to JavaScript files.
What do I mean by
platform-specific Kotlin, the
reference pages for each of the
Kotlin packages, you mouse over
any of them, in the top-right,
you see these multi-colored
chips that tell you which
compilation target this is
available on.  The Kotlin
browser package, that lets you
access interfaces from the web
browser environment only makes
sense on the JS target.
Fortunately, they are available
all cross all the compilation
targets.  You can see Kotlin
Common.  This is a pure Kotlin
library that can run independent
from any platform it's
targeting.
In fact, if you add
multi-platform plugin to your
project, along with the
platform-specific set, you get a
common source set where you can
put platform-independent code.
The thing about
platform-independent code, it
cannot call any of the platform
APIs.  It cannot call any of the
JS-specific or Android-specific
APIs.  The other way works.  You
can have your platform-specific
code, it depends on a shared
common library or source set.
So, knowing all that, I set out
to write an example app just to
learn about Kotlin a platform
and I wrote a game.  I still
need to create an Android app
with Android-specific code just
like I normally would and then a
web page with JavaScript code to
initialize things to my app.  In
my case, the sudoku engine, I
take it out and put it in a
shared library used Kotlin
Common.  And in fact, the only
source set I have is common main
so I put all my code there and
that means it's available across
all the platforms I choose to
target.
But then I thought, okay, I have
this core engine for solving my
code but I would also like to
draw the board on my screen and
why code it separately if it
should look the same on each of
them?  Wouldn't it be nice if I
had an API the drawing on the
screen?  But then what I want to
do is I want to actually have it
delegate to each of the
platform's implementation.  I
want to use the Android canvas
and the HTML to draw on the
website.  The thing is, I just
told you that Kotlin Common code
cannot call any platform
interfaces so I can't depends on
these.  How does it work in
Kotlin?
Well, there's this expect an
actual mechanism that lets you
declare expected classes in your
common code, which is like
almost defining an interface in
Java.  In my platform-specific
source sets, I provide the
actual implementation that can
use APIs, just as the Android
canvas.
Now, when I add that dependency
from my common source set to the
other one, it looks something
like this.  But, actually, when
compiling for a specific
platform, such as JS, this
dependency will actually use
HTML canvas.
[Laughter]
Okay.  If I could just show the
link to the project so that
everyone can look at it, that
would be great.
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Yeah, that's it.
[Applause and cheers]
I guess not.
[Laughter]
I'm Nick Butcher.  I'm a
designer and
engineer at Google and I love
vectors.  Most assets in your
applications should be vectors
these days.  Vectors are
awesome.  They're sharp on every
single density display.  They're
also extremely flexible and I
want to talk about this so you
can get the most out of vectors.
So, most vectors in your app
probably look something like
this.  They have parts and
hard-coding a color.  Something
like this, fill or stroke here.
Maybe you're using a color
resource.  There's a lot more
you can do here.  The first
thing is using theme colors.
So, you can use theme colors in
two ways.  You can apply a theme
color as a tint.  It will tint
the entire drawable.  Here is
for the icons and you can have
one, single asset that displays
in different themes.  You no
longer have to worry what color
asset you got from your
designers, that they got exactly
the right shade of gray you
need.  It will be tinted at
runtime so it's always correct.
In this example, I'm going to
use color primary.  Say you have
a sports app, which using a
theme for a given team.  You can
reference that theme color so
you have a single drawable.
Vector support and lists, you
can do some fun stuff.  We're
changing color.  Or perhaps you
have a list app where when a row
item is selected, you can change
the renderings.  You could do
this with a drawable and flip
between them.  If the rendering
is 99% the same, you want to
save the stroke here, this saves
duplication.  You define it like
this in your color resources and
refer to it as you would like a
color resource.
My favorite feature is gradient.
Vectors support linear, radial
and sweep.  A linear has a
start, end,
X y coordinate
s.
You can actually get much more
fine-grained and embed these
tags inside it to find
individual color stops.  Here,
I'm going for a color at 72% of
the way through.
You define gradients in a
directory or the in-line
resource syntax and it build
time, it will extract it to a
color resource, which is handy.
Gradients have been super handy.
Here's an illustration from an
I/O app.  It would have been
one-fifth of the what we had to
ship.  It's useful for adaptive
icons.  Vectors don't support
drop shadows.  If you need to
build a customized spinner, this
is necessary to achieve.
Gradients have certain shapes,
but they can be transformed,
like rotated and so on.  I
wanted to create this
oval-shaped shadow.  So I did
this by drawing a circle with a
radial gradient and using the
scale y feature to transform it
to produce the effect that is
after.  If it doesn't fill the
entire shape, you can use this.
It continues to color outwards.
If you use a repeat mode, it
will repeat and continue.  Or a
mirror mode will go back and
forth through the gradient.
You can also use gradients which
don't go through different
colors.  You can have the solid
color block.  Why would you want
a gradient that doesn't do that?
You can have some fun.  This
example is one single shape
using a radial gradient.  You
can do a loading spinner or
combine it.  This is the
gradient over this area and you
can have some fun animating it.
So, hopefully I've shown you
that vectors are sharp, small
and effective.  I want to show
you what you can build.  This is
a single drawable vector.  I had
the pleasure of animating it.
This is one vector drawable,
extremely small, extremely
sharp.  That's vector drawables.
Thank you very much.
[Applause]
We have a short pause while we
have the next session queuing
up.  I hope you enjoyed that
vector-oriented presentation.
We're going to get into a little
bit of
Data Binding,
hopefully.
So, how's everyone enjoying the
summit so far?
[Applause and cheers]
I want a little bit more
enthusiasm, but I'll take it.
[Laughter]
And, we are so excited to be
doing this again.  It's the
first time we've done this in
three years and it is so great
to get out in front of you for
Android's 10th anniversary.
And, again, thank you, all.  I
know many of you -- how many of
you traveled for more than 1,000
miles to be here.  Wow!  All
right.  That's amazing.
We're almost there, I think.
All right.  Hold on, we're
having technical difficulties.
Are we ready?  All right.
Excellent.  Let's do this.
Level Up with Data Binding.
When Data Binding was back in
2015, my reaction was, what have
we done?  Expressions.  Data
Binding is pretty cool.  You can
actually choose how much you
want to use.  It's the beginner
level.  Immediate benefits.  At
the intermediate level, you get
custom binding adapters.  You
have data from UI and UI to
data.  Let's get rid of find
view by ID.
[Applause and cheers]
We need to enable Data Binding.
All you have to do is set Data
Binding equals true in your
Gradle file and put layout
wrappers.  You can do that in
Android Studio automatically
know by pulling down and saying
convert to Data Binding layout.
You can inflate it and set your
attributes like this.  You're
going to want to use real Data
Binding so let's talk about
binding expressions.  We declare
variables in this data section
of our layout and then we can
use expressions in layout Xml
attributes.  They are in curly
braces.  Here are examples.
We're designing a text property
to a ViewModel property.  In the
second one, height of zero and
in the third one, we use a
lambda, which gets past the text
few.  On the fourth one, it has
another view.
Now, to give Data Binding
access, we set the binding
object like this after inflating
the layout.  So, pretty
straightforward and then our
ViewModel is now available to
that layout.  But the real
question is, how does this all
work?  And the answer is, there
is no magic in Data Binding.
But it does seem like Meige
magic and that's because we have
adapters.  Every call is made a
binding adapter.  You can see
the code and use a debugger.
That last line is actually the
set text we're looking for.
They make it behave
intelligently across all these
views.
Looking at the source files will
help you build your own custom
binding adapters.  So, let's
talk about it.  The adapters
take one or more attribute
names.  The method takes a view
of the first
parameter.  They can just --
adapters can differ just by data
types.  So you can also use
adapters to override the
behavior.  This makes the image
load glide but you have to be
careful with this.  We also
could do a bunch of stuff with
advanced binding adapters.
Sometimes the old one is good,
like listener.  The binding
compiler will pass the old one
into the first one.
And, also, you can use
multiattributes, which is pretty
cool.  So you can define these
multiple attributes here, when
you declare the binding adapter
and those are both available to
your code.  Observebility is
cool.  We can use LiveData to
automatically do observation.
This is pretty cool.  We're only
exposing an immutable class
here.  And then you just expose
a LiveData using Kotlin.
And then you need to do one more
additional change.  You need to
set the lifecycle owner so you
can observe it.
Two-way Data Binding.  This is
really trivial when you're
actually using LiveData.  You
can use one-way Data Binding in
two ways.  You can actually call
this with two-way Data Binding
with at equals.  We can observe
LiveData.  So, in this case,
it's fine to expose it and then
we set the lifecycle owner and
we use at the at equals notation
and that's it.  Two-way Data
Binding.  Maybe that's not so
expert anymore.
Check out the Data Binding
codelab.  There you go.
[Applause]
Hey, everyone.  My name is
Carmen and I'm on the Android
performance team and today I'm
going to show you examples of
analyzing performance using
Systrace.  Before I do, I want
to remind you that your app is
not an island.  It's running on
top of several layers, the phone
hardware, the Android framework,
libraries, AB tests.  The
reality might actually surprise
you.  And this is where Systrace
comes in.  So Systrace is a tool
that let's you collect precise
timing information about what's
going on, on your device, and
visual it.  It records down to
the individual CPU time slice.
It's the most important tool we
have for debugging issues.  We
have given talks about how to
use Systrace in the past.
Google for the I/O talk.
Today, I want to talk about the
issues you can find.  I used
Systrace for three apps I don't
use.  Let's jump in.  With the
first app, when I look at the
trace, three different activity
starts jumped out at me right
away.  There's a lot of reasons
to use trampoline activities.  I
see when developers are trying
to use a splash screen.  They
definitely impact your launch
time.  If you're trying to make
a splash screen, you could set
up a launch theme or refactor
your code so you only open the
separate activity when you need
to.  I don't know why this app
has these activities, maybe they
are critical.
In the same app, I also browsed
through the names of the views,
it looks like it's a drawer
views.  They often have a lot of
child views.  Sometimes we need
them immediately for UX reasons.
They could save 42 more mill
seconds.
The second app is following what
I would expect.  There's no
extra activities or services
being started.  I dug in more
and clicked on the views being
inflated and the names of the
widgets I could see matched up
with what was visible with the
app.  Then I saw this gap in
activity inside blind
application that takes up 30
milli seconds.  I'll see its
monitor contention.  Monitor
contention is saying lock
contention, where the owner of
the lock of the thread.  And so
I scrolled down and I did see
activity during this time.
And then it's giving me a
pointer to the stack.  I wasn't
familiar with realm.  It's like
a mobile database library like
Sequel.  This may be or may not
be something you can fix because
you might need to coordinate
with the Realm
library.
Either way, this is another
potentialpotential 30 mill
second.
There are two activities being
started, but there's another
potential improvement here.  I
included the thread name, this
is the UI thread.  If we scroll
down, we can see these
background threads running.  CPU
0, CPU 1 CPU 2.  It's awesome
they made background threads but
there's a potential performance
issue.  These background threads
are doing a lot of blocking I/O.
So that's the orange sections.
They're kind of hard to see.
So you can see there's some I/O
happening.  Now it turns out
that on a lot of devices, we
have to be concerned about I/O
contention.  There's not
necessarily more than one
channel to use.  They may be
slowing down the I/O request
from the UI thread.  That is
highlighted down below.  We see
the busy 4 milli seconds.  We
can see that in this section, we
spend 107 milli seconds.  We
could shorten this if we move
the background activity and
overlap with is somening else.
All I needed to do was clone.
You can open the output HTML
file in your browser and see
everything that I showed you
today.  And this barely
scratches the surface of what
you can do with Systrace.  I was
able to identify these
opportunities in apps I don't
work on.
When you look at a trace of your
own app, it's going to make 100
times more sense to you.  And,
you can even add your own trace
points inside your app code so
you can see the context of
what's running in your app from
within the trace.
Thank you.
[Applause]
PRAEF
Hi, everyone.  Hope we've been
enjoying the day one so far.
I'm parul.  We want to talk to
you about certain practices that
you, as app developers can adopt
to build products that continue
to value users, at the same
time, protect their right to
privacy.  We want Android to be
a platform where you can offer
personalized experiences and at
the same time, privacy is
important and transparency in
terms of what data you're
collecting and how you're using
it.
So, it can serve as a platform
to build social experiences.  We
have ongoing efforts.  So,
things we want to touch upon
today are how your apps are
accessing user data, ensuring
your user's know what is being
accessed and transparency.
So, we have a multi-level
approach.  We focus on improving
APIs.
We set up for keeping abuse in
check and assuring that a level
playing field is provided and a
safe experience for our users.
We've built out to identify
when apps may be abusing a
user's personal information.
We also have human reviewers,
so it's not bots and AI, but
actually people who review the
apps to make sure the user's
right to privacy is secured and
the safe experience is provided.
We also invest heavily in
surcurity.  We have the security
program and vulnerability
program.  Feel free to drop more
if you want to know more about
these.
Finally, we have Google Play,
which helps users conserve their
privacy and security -- sorry.
Why are we here speaking to
you today?  We feel privacy and
security is a partnership
between the platform and
developers, as you.  You, as
developers, who build these
apps, play a very big role in
the ecosystem.  You can advocate
for better privacy policies and
ensure it is not compromised at
the right of users privacy.
For example, if you have a
request to collect certain
information about a user from
their device, a question all way
worth asking is, do we really
need it?  How do you plan to use
it?  And are we still using it?
There reason is that it is
actually not really uncommon for
certain information to be
collected, which is actually
never used and is sometimes
abandoned.
Some data we see being
collected includes IMI, a list
of installed apps, to target ads
to them.  Collecting information
of an app information or a
network, such as the name or
strength.  You probably always
don't need such information.
So, for a few cases, we have
privacyprivacy options.  Some
examples include we encourage
you to use instance IDs.  If
you're trying to confirm the
user's phone number, we
recommend you use this.  You can
also consider qualification
instead of fine location and
then if you want to see if a
user in the core, you could
check for the focus rather than
requesting the read phone state,
which gives out a lot more data.
Lastly, you want to ensure
that your users are available of
what data is being collected and
how it is being used.  This is
not just a best practice, but a
requirement.  If a user is not
aware that some data about them
is about to be collected and for
what purpose it is being used,
you are required to disclose it
to them and get permission to do
so.
The data's being collected off
the in-store app for fraud
prevention purposes so this
needed to be disclosed to the
user and only after the user
consents to it should the data
be transferred.
We've worked hard and we're
going to walk you through a few
of those changes.  In Android 9,
we split up the call log
permissions from the phone
permission group into their own
permission group call log.  If
your app is requesting --
reading phone numbers from the
phone's state broadcast chain,
we are requesting you to ask for
a call log and state
permissions.
In Android 8, replaced it with a
build with function that
requires a read phone state
permission.  Please make sure
you use if for valid reasons.
Speaking of limited access,
apps running in the background
will require the following
restriction s. You will no
longer have access to mic or
camera in the background,
sensors.  If your app needs
access to sensor events on
devices, you will need to use a
full-ground service and to
further-inform and protect the
user, the system will add a
visual aid when they are
accessing the camera or mic.
Our contacts provided API used
to allow apps to provide data to
glean information.  As of
January next year, a limited set
of contact fields and methods
will be made obsolete.
So if your app is accessing or
updating these fields, we ask
you to use alternative methods.
You could fulfill certain use
cases by using private content
providers or storing data in
your back-end systems.
So this was a really brief
talk.  We hope we've been able
to offer you insight to build
apps that are conscious.  As
we've mentioned, we definitely
believe that security and
privacy is a partnership between
you, the developer, and our
platform.  If you have any
questions about it, please do
come find us at the office hours
and I hope you have a great
summit.  Thank you so much.
Thank you.
[Applause]
Contained a guide to app
architecture, which shows one
way they can combine to have a
testable and maintainable app.
The separation
of concerns   Hello, everyone.
It's great to be here.  My name
is Phil Adams.  I'm a
researcher.
And I'm Pierre Lecesne.
We're here to talk about how
we're rethinking app
distribution on Google Play.
We'll talk about the format and
share features we've been
working on.  Tostart with, let's
talk about app size and the
impact it's having on your app.
Why does app size even matter?
We shared this chart at Google
I/O and you saw it earlier
today.  It shows when the app
gets bigger, install success
rate goes down.  Many users
don't have enough space left on
their device. Data can be
expensive and connection speeds,
slow.  I want you to think about
your own experience, too.  How
many have you seen a warning
from Play?
We've started looking into this
area more closely and found that
freeing up space is a major
driver of uninstalls.  This is a
problem for people with
low-storage devices.
It's also a problem with
high-end devices who fill up the
devices with HD content.  One in
five devices in the U.K. have
low storage.  A key request we
hear from developers is also for
help understanding and
uninstalls.  We ran a user
research study to see why users,
in the U.S., uninstall apps.
The leading reason was quality.
However, the leading reason apps
games were uninstalled after a
month was to free-up space.
Apps and games keep getting
bigger.  They have grown over
five times on average.  Newer
devices have more storage, but
the app, games, photos and HD
videos keep getting bigger, too.
Making your app big puts it at
risk to suffer from all these
downsides.  They lose
acquisitions and get uninstalled
to free up space.  I'm sure you
already know that and you've
probably just considered it a
trade-off.  Do you add new
features?  Lose installs and
drive more uninstalls?  We don't
want you to have to worry about
these trade-offs.
For a few years, there's been a
way to optimize.  You can use
multiple SDKs, but
it's incredibly inefficient.  In
number of APKs grows quickly, 64
bits, 34 bits.
It also doesn't help with some
of the dimensions.  The
languages are in every APK.  We
can do better.  Let us show you
the solution we have built for
this and see how the new app
model helps make your life
easier.
So, the new app model is focus
on improving the whole user
acquisition journey.  It helps
by making your apps smaller,
directly improving install and
uninstall rates.  It makes your
releasing more manageable.
In that context, for the rest of
today's session, we'll talk
about steps we want to help you
with.  First, we want to help
you convert more installs and
minimize uninstalls by building
smaller apps.  Then, we want to
make it possible for you to
deliver different features to
different audiences, on-demand.
And, finally, we want to help
you keep your users up-to-date
on the latest and greatest
versions of your app.
Let's start with how to make
your app smaller.  This is where
we good be gan with the App
Bundle.  It is the app
publishing format.  Apps that
have adopted it have seen a
saving of 35%.  That's compared
to a universal APK and that's
quite a bit.  How does it lead
to such savings?  Here's the big
idea, Google Play can assist and
take care of delivering just
what's needed on your behalf.
There's no need to send a bunch
of languages and device
resources.  We support three
slices dimensions out of the
box, language, screen densities
and architecture.  All of this
is made possible by split APKs,
we added in Android Lollipop.
Split APKs allow multiple APKs
to be on one app.  They can be
installed in different
combinations, on different
devices and can be installed all
at once or piece by piece.
Given a bundle, Google Play
starts by putting everything
that is common in the base APK.
This is the manue fest and dex
files.  We
generate a different MRIT APK.
It is all the drawables that
would have had that device and
density.
We then also generate different
split APKs for each native
architecture and generate a
separate split for each language
supported by your app putting
each string in a different APK.
Together, we call these
configuration splits or config
splits.
When we go to serve an app to
a device, we only need to serve
a portion.  We will install the
base APKs, as well as the
density split, the architecture
split and the English language
split.  It can get a bit
trickier than that.  I speak
both French and English and have
specified both languages so my
pixel will not only receive the
correct density and architecture
split, but the French and
English language splits.  If I
move to Brazil and learn
Portuguese, it will attempt to
download the language split for
all the apps on my phone.
For devices, which don't support
it, they with have stand-alone
APKs for API and screen density.
Each of these contain all the
necessary files.  My old Galaxy
will run it.  All the languages
are included in those APKs.
Putting it all together, the
picture looks like this.  You
actually don't need to worry
about all the details of how
these APKs are generated.  All
you have to do is upload a
single app bundle and select the
right things to serve for each
device.
To summarize, the App Bundle
contains everything, signs each
APK to deliver to devices.
Because Play is now signing the
APKs, this means you need to
upload your signing key to
Google Play.  This is part of
the program
called App signing by Play.
Is this secure?  The answer is,
absolutely.  As you can imagine,
Google takes this very
seriously.  We protect your key
in the same storage we protect
Google's own keys.  You'll
benefit from our owngoing
investments.
We've been chatting to
developers who are already using
the App Bundle about what they
like.  Recently, we've conducted
a workshop with developers from
India, they have millions of
active installs and they're very
sophistsophisticated about
keeping their app sizes small.
It improves their conversion
rates.
Red Bus says it is more
streamlined.  Switching was a
simple process and they were
testing with the bundle within
an hour.  It's just not
developers in India, all the
developers have switched and
have seen fantastic-size
savings.  56% size saving
compared to a universal APK.
It's hard to get that from
incremental.
Google apps are adopting the
bundle and production and seeing
strong savings, as well.  Google
MapsMaps, Google News 27, they
report streamlining of their
release process and noticed
isn't experimental, this is
ready.  There are thousands of
apps --
thousands of app bundle s in
production.
So, when you adopt the App
Bundle, you're not only gaining
size saving, today, you'll be
benefiting from automatic
optimizations.  Here is another
one.  We've added a new Android
platform to the App Bundle
called uncompressed native
libraries.  Native libraries
have to be uncompressed from the
APK before the platform can use
them.  The end user ends up with
two copies of the library.  They
can read it directly from the
APK if it's left uncompressed.
You will need two versions of
your app.  If you're using the
App Bundle, you give us your
libraries and we re-create it.
The size savings we're seeing
are around 16% reduction on size
and 8% reduction in download
size.  As I explained, the app
is smaller on disk because it
does not need to make a copy.
It is smaller because our
compression algorithms perform
better on data that is not
already compressed.  Our partner
saw savings of 22% and 16% on
their download size.  And these
savings are in addition to the
size savings they're already
seeing.
With this optimizing, the
download size is smaller, faster
to install and takes up less
room on disk.
Now, we still want you to remain
in control to when these
optimizations should be pushed
to your users.  Play will only
apply optimizations that have
been built with the version of
Gradle that introduces the
optimization.  The uncompressed
native libraries will only be
applied to your app if you build
it with Gradle 3.3.
Now, let's take a look at how
you can build, test and publish
Android App Bundles.  You can
build App Bundle in the 3.2
stable release of Android
Studio.  It is very similar to
building an APK for most
developers so it's easy to
switch.
For who prefer the command line
or wish to integrate with
automated build systems, the
Gradle Android plugin provides
tasks to build bundles.  You
would use the assemble task.
With the Android App Bundle, you
use the new bundle task.
Similar to assemble tasks, you
can build specific flavors.
The bundle task will generate an
Android app bundle with flavor
and build type chosen.  It is
called bundle.aab.
We do want developeressess to
retain control over their
splits.  If you need to disable
splitting, you can do so using
the new bundle block, as shown
here.
Android Studio and Gradle are
not only ways you can build
bundles today.  They are open
source, others are already
adopting them.  Games using
Unity can build Android App
Bundles, too.  They added
support in the beta release and
you can join the beta program
now.
So, now, let's see how you can
adapt your testing.  During the
development phase, when you need
to iterate quickly, you don't
need to go through the App
Bundle.  You can build through
Studio, much faster.  Before a
release, you may want to test
the APKs that would be generated
from the App Bundle.  This is as
easy as creating a new run
configuration and selecting APK
from App Bundle.  Studio, under
the hood, uses the same tool
Play does so we'll get high
fidelityfidelity.
When you want to share the APKs,
generated from the app bundle,
you can use it.  This is what
Play and Gradle use on their
hood to generate APKs.  It is
transparent about how we
generate APKs and you can
download it on the GitHub repo
you see here.
It generates what we call an
APK-set archive which will
contain all the APKs for all the
devices that your app supports.
You can share this archive and
still use bundle tool, which
will simulate what Play does.
As you can imagine, an APK set
can become quite big so if you
want to build it for a given
device, you can do it with
specification.  You can share it
around and can be installed on
the devices.
This is what the common line
looks like, to build the APK set
archive.  In this case, when
instructor bundle to build APKs
only for the connected device.
If you don't have a device
at-hand, if you're generating it
from a CI system, you can do
device specification in this
JSON format.
If you want a unique APK, you
can build a universal APK.  It
can be installed on any device
and is very convenient for
sharing.
The best way is to go through
the internal test track on the
console.  You can get, bite for
bite, what your userishess will
get.  It is similar to
the alpha and beta tracks.
There is no delay between the
upload and
being avail on the device.
You can create a list of emails.
The testers can follow the link
and they'll receive
automatically the latest
version.
We know that for some of you,
these testing options are not
ideal and we see a gap in
testing with Android Studio and
tracks.  We're thinking really
hard about how to close this
gap.
So now you've built and tests
bundles, let's talk about a new
view.  In the Play console,
we're starting to show an
estimate when we think an app
could benefit from the App
Bundle.  We'll calculate what
you could save if you switch.
Once you choose to switch, you
manage your release just like
you did with APKs.  Simply
create a new release and drop
the App Bundle in the same
location.  In order to aid your
migration, you can upload APKs
on your production track.  When
you do this, Play is not going
to reassign the APK.
We did this so you can feel
confident feeling out the App
Bundle with a small amount of
users first.
Once you've uploaded it, you
review your release, you roll it
out.  And that's it.  I can't
stress this enough, there's no
multi-APK to deal with.  Play
console has created all the APKs
for the devices supported for
you.
Now that you've uploaded your
App Bundle and Play's done this
heavy lifting, it would be nice
to have an overview of what Play
has done for you.  We've built a
new tool called bundle explorer,
which lets you navigate your
uploaded bundles.
On the first screen of bundle
explorer, you'll see the size
savings.  This is going to be
different, device by device, so
we calculated this using a
popular configeration.  If you
click on view devices, you can
see which devices are in each
bucket.
Alternatively, you can search
for supported device by name to
download the set of generated
APKs that get served to that
particular device.  This is
helpful when you get a bug
report so you can get the exact
APKs that Play has served to it.
We haven't forgotten about
everyone who uses our publishing
APKs, it is available by the API
and automation and CI tools are
adopting the bundle.  You will
find all the documentation as
these URLs.
[No
audio].
You can reduce the size of
your app.  Some features may be
used by 10% of your users, to
avoid having the disk space for
a feature they don't use, you
can choose to retract it.
Dynamic features can be used or
you can defer them from
installing them to a later time
when the app goes [no
audio].
They evaluate the app size
impact to ensure that the
benefit of the feature is worth
the size increase.  Dynamic
features mean they can increase
it.
Dynamic features help Facebook
with their high-end strategy.
They are able to deliver
advanced features to just
supported devices and remove
larming features that are not
used often to avoid taking up
space on that device forever.
Facebook has told us that
dynamic features work well when
they are working on a new
feature.  They can have a
separate team of engineers
working on it and they can add
the app and add it to the app
without increasing the base app
size at install time.
Here are some of the examples of
dynamic features.  They are in
production.  Froexample, card
scanning is a feature that only
a small percentage of users are
using.  It avoids it taking 2
megabytes.  Another one is
realtime communication.  Only
users with devices who can
support them and actually want
to use them need to download it.
What might that experience look
like for a user?  Let's take a
simple example.  Imagine that
you have a recipe app and you
want to keep it small.  While
all of your users like to browse
for recipes, only a small
fraction of them like to add
recipes and you notice that this
takes up significant size in
your app.  You can choose to
break these feature out into its
own module and serve it only
when needed.  We can see what it
looks like for the user here.
The app opens, and then the user
goes to add a recipe.  The app
then requested the module be
installed.  It's downloaded with
progress visible to the user and
it's ready to be used after a
few seconds.
Which parts of your apps might
make good candidates to be
broken out?  If only a small
fraction of your users, use this
feature, it could be a good
candidate.  And finally,
consider if users can wait a few
seconds before downloading and
using that feature.
If you're interested in
modularizing your app, I
encourage you to look the
articles.
Now that we have covered how
dynamic features work, let's see
how to create them.  To create a
dynamic module in Android
3.0, use the wizard.  Choose
dynamic feature module.  Type in
your module's name and Android
Studio will download a new
feature for you.  Under the
hood, this is what Studio does.
A split identifier is added.  In
this case, we'll call it add
recipient.  This is how the
Android platform recognizes that
although this APK has the same
package name, it's a different
module name.
A new tag is added for
distribution aspects.  It reads
properties of the modules of
your app.
Next, you declare that this is
an on-demand module, meaning
that it will be only delivered
to users devices when you
request it.  Note that on-demand
modules are only supported since
Android L so you need to specify
what Play should do when it
generates the pre-L APKs. This
is configuring using the fusing
tag.
Here's an example with our
recipe app.  We have two dynamic
features.  It has equal true and
the module is fuse equals false.
You can see that Play will only
add it in the pre-L APK.
In the dynamic module, you can
see a new Gradle plugin being
used.  You also have to add the
base module to access
functionality from the base
module.  Looking at the build
Gradle, the only change is to
declare all dynamic modules.
Gradle will make the resources
stored available to them.
Now that we've created our
on-demand modules, let's write
the code to download them.  In
order to interact with the Play
store, we have to use the split
install API, which is part of
the Play core library.  This is
a library that communicates with
the Play store.  The Play store
communicates with Play servers.
The API is structured using the
same task framework from Google
Play services.  Installations is
by the split manager.  You
construct a request with all the
modules you wish to download and
install the splits required for
the requested modules.
For large modules, you'll need
to obtain the user confirmation.
You'll need to do this whenever
an app requests more than 10
mega bytes.  You can listen for
updates and display this
progress to users.  Here, we
show the download progress bar.
Alternative option is to use
the deferred installation API.
These will be installed at a
convenient time for the user,
generally when they aren't using
the device and are on WiFi and
charging.
Because of this, we allow you to
install up to 100 megabytes with
our requiring user confirmation.
It allows you to manage your
on-demand modules.  You can
uninstall modules that are no
longer required by the app.
So, when installing an on-demand
module, the app does not need to
be restarted.  Code is available
immediately and your resources
and assets are available once
you refresh the content object.
On Android L And M, it needs to
fully restart.  We include a
split library which has splits
for L and M until the app goes
into the background and we can
properly install it.  If you are
familiar with it, you will set
up split compat in a very
similar way.
You can use the split
application as you default
application or you can simply
extend.  And if none of these
options suit you, you can choose
to override the context in your
application and invoke split
compat at install.
Now, let's talk about
versioning.  When you release an
adate to your app, Play ilwill
update the base module and any
on-demand modules so the version
of your modules are always in
sync.  Partners tell us this is
something they really like about
this model.
Let's now talk about the final
step here, helping users update
to the latest and greatest
version of your app.  You know
that Play offers auto update
functionality and many users do
have automatic updates turned
on.  In some markets, it's not
uncommon to have it turned on
but their device to not meet the
requirements.  For example, they
might not connect to WiFi.
I'm
happy to share we're launching a
new feature.  You can call this
API to determine first there is
an update available and then if
so, you can share a prompt to
your user s.  The flow is
designed to immediate critical
use cases, such as user privacy
or revenue-affecting bugs.  It's
a full-screen experience where
the user is expected to wait for
the update to be applied.  We
take of restarting the app for
you.
Some of you have built similar
flows for yourselves.  But this
is a standardized method that
you can use with very little
effort.
Instead of that immediate
update, you can also put
together a flexible update which
does not have to be applied
straight away.  The really cool
thing about this API is that you
completely customize the update
flow so that it feels like part
of your app.  You may choose to
nudge users, like Google Chrome
is doing in this example.  The
download happens in the
background so the user can keep
using the app.  The update is
complete, it's up to you, and
your app, to decide how to
prompt the user to restart.  Or
you can simply wait until the
app goes into the background.
Google Chrome is testing this
now and we're inviting early
access partners to start testing
this with us, as well.  Talk to
your manager if you're
interested.
Let's take a look at the code
that allows that flexible in-app
update to work.  First, you can
request an instance of app
update manager.  And then
request the app update info.
This result is going to contain
the update availability status.
If an update is available and
the update is allowed, the
returned app update contains an
intent to start the flow.
If the app is allowed to start,
you would extract this pending
intent and start it.  This will
start the download and
installation.
You can monitor the state of an
update by registering a listener
for status updates.  When the
download is complete, you can
choose to install it directly or
defer to install it.  The
restart happens when a complete
update is called.
So to recap this new API,
ensuring your users get the
latest update is important.  And
you can make that happen by
following some of these
best-practices up here on the
screen and also by integrating
by our in-app updates API.  The
API is available for any app and
so you can get started with it,
in parallel to switching with
the App Bundle.
And, that's it.  We've now
covered how to make your apps
smaller and create dynamic
features and how you can ensure
that your users stay on the
latest version of your app.
If you want to chat, you can
find us in the office hours.  If
you want to share about what
we've talked about, the post of
this link is a great place to
start.  Enjoy the rest of your
day.  Thank you.
[Applause]
Everyone, the next session, in
this room, begins promptly, at
2:50.  Thank you.
Good afternoon, everyone.
Our program will resume in three
minutes.  We remind you, as a
courtesy to the presenters, to
please mute all mobile devices.
Thank
you.
Thank you.
Hi, my name is Kodlee.
And I'm Rasekh.  Here to talk
to you about what's new about
app developer and Android Auto.
We're excited about the
automotive space right now,
connectivity, electrification.
Cars are turning into full-blown
computers on wheel.  They have
cameras, screens of all shapes
and sizes everywhere.
Android Auto is an effort from
Google and our automotive
partners to bring these together
and bring a safe experience for
drivers everywhere.  Of course,
that's easier said than done.
Many different input types, from
touchscreens to touch pads, many
different screen shapes, sizes
and resolutions.  Today, you can
see that vision at work in any
Android Auto-compatible carment
drivers have access to their
favorite apps right from their
car's display and developers
build their app once without
worrying about different makes
and models.  Today, we'll talk
about two of the most important
app categories,
mesinging and media.
First is
messaging.  That's where
CarExtender came into play.
CarExtender allowed a way for
messaging apps to provide
details and a way to reply to
conversations to Android Auto.
But sense Android N, apps could
stylize their notifications with
MessagingStyle.  It is a huge
step up for CarExtender, as it
allows messaging apps to bring
conversation into the
notification.  Not only does it
provide a nicer UI, but it
provides affordances like
applying and liking.
Android Auto now fully-supports
the use of MessagingStyle
without the need for
CarExtender.  This means Android
Auto and the assistant allow
group messaging.  For
MessagingStyle, apps not only
gain a richer user experience
and the benefit of automotive
support.
So, let's see how Android Auto
interfaces with this, starting
on the messaging app side.  From
Android Auto's point of view,
messaging apps have three core
functions.  Notifying users of
messages, marking those messages
as read and replying.  Apps can
implement reading and replying
with services.  These services
can be triggered inturnally with
intents or externally with
pending intents.  Notifying is
done via an Android notification
and the messaging information is
provided with the
MessagingStyle.  The mark is
read and reply are wrapped in
intentions.  Note here that the
reply action has a remote input
that's added, that acts an input
field for the reply.
And that's the messaging app's
architecture.  Moving on to the
other side of the notification,
we can see how Android Auto
leverages these objects.  They
will post an in-car notification
and once tapped on, will read
aloud the messages.  The mark is
read pending.  The user's given
the choice to respond and if
taken, a transcription of that
response is set in that remote
input.  The reply pending intent
is then fired.
And that's the entire Android
Auto flow so let's see how we
can put that into code.  First,
the app needs to declare support
for Android Auto.  To do that,
it needs to create a new XML
file linked in the Android
manifest.  This file says that
it has notifications that
Android Auto should take a look
at.  Note that for messaging
apps that support SMS, this
needs to be added.  So, now
Android Auto's taking a look at
our messages, we can build up
the messaging style.  We can't
really have a conversation
without people so we have to add
the user of the device.  We
create a new person object.
Person is used to set things
like the user's name, their icon
and unique key.  So, we create
this device user and we create
the MessagingStyle with it.  We
can add our conversation
information.
So, I'm from Seattle and I love
skiing so I'm setting it to ski
group.  Because I'm taking
multiple friends, this is a
group conversation so the
messaging app needs to set it as
such.  Note here that
conversation title and whether
or not the conversation is a
group can be set independently.
This is new in Android P and has
been back-ported in the compat
library.
Finally, we can add all the
messages in this conversation in
the order they were received.
In this case, my friend wants to
coordinate breakfast, so there's
the text, the timestamp and the
sender.  With this conversation
set up, it's time to add the
actions.  For the reply action,
we in stantiate an action
building and set the semantic
action to semantic action reply.
That must also tell the OS that
firing the reply pending intent
won't show any extra UI.  This
is especially important in
Android Auto because we don't
want to be distracting users.
The reply action is supplied
with that remote input I talked
about earlier.  On the mark as
read side, it is done the same
way.  It is set to semantic
action, mark as read and we tell
the OS that pending that intent
won't show extra UI.  The mark
as read action does not need a
remote input.
So that's all three pieces, the
notification can now be built.
For reference, here are the
three elements we created.
MessagingStyle, which holds our
conversation, reply and mark as
read action.  To build a
notification, some boilerplate
is provided and we set the
messaging style.  We can add our
actions.  Here is where the
messaging app has some options.
The reply is a regular, visible
action and the mark as read is
added as invisible.  One can add
both as visible or invisible.
This changes how it shows up in
the mobile UI.  On Android Auto,
actions are never shown but it
can read visible and invisible
actions.
The messaging app can post the
notification and now we have
planned breakfast on the road
and our ski trip is under way.
And now that we've coordinated
with everybody, let's find
something to listen to.  Getting
driver's access to their content
should be front and center.  I'm
going to talk about new features
to enhance the usability of
media apps.  We want to make it
more visually pleasing and
enabling search results.  Let's
go over the architecture that an
app has when communicating with
the Android Auto.  The first
thing a media app is a media
browser service.  It provides a
tree of playable and browsable
items.  Browsable items are
basically things to organize app
content instead of returning a
giant list of playable items.
They implement the ownload
children method, which adds the
tree.  Here in our first call,
it would return home, recently
played, recommended and play
lists.  Since this is running in
a car, we recommend that media
apps only provide two levels in
the tree to avoid distracting
drivers.
Now, once a user has picked
something playable from the
browse tree, the media session
service is used to play music
and provide metadata and
controls.  For example, our
media app supports play/pause,
play forward and skip back.
There's also the ability to
provide their own custom
actions, maybe something like
30-second skip.  Obviously, we
want to get the user away from
touches or doing things so we
bring in the assistant.  Might
say something like, hey, Google,
play my ski jams.  They perform
speech recognition and request
that it play the query and music
starts playing.
We're going to take a one step
farther today.  We're giving you
the ability for media apps to
implement an additional
function, onsearch, and once the
music has started playing from a
Google Assistant query, they can
provide additional results.  It
provided a ski trip from this
year, as well as last year.
This should look pretty
familiar.  This is the onsearch
method.  It takes the query
string, an extras bundle and a
result object which the app
fills in and sends back to
Android Auto.  Apps should
return an empty list if they get
a query they don't support.
Second, for queries
that can't be answered sink
cruinously, it let's them know
not to send anything back right
away.  Apps can do extra work
before sending the results to
Android Auto.
Finally, when the results are
ready, they can send the result
and the result object and
Android Auto will be notified
and show the results on-screen.
All the code snippets come from
the universal music player, an
open source media app published
on GitHub.  It can be cloned,
compiled and used as a great
reference building your own
media app.
So, our media app returns a list
of items in the ski jams query.
It returns two play lists and an
album.  It could be nice to
Android Auto could group those
items.  Fortunately, we're
introducing a way to do that.
Here's an example function where
your media app might use from an
internal representation of a
media item into the media item
compat.  We can annotate items
with a category extra and
Android Auto will group any
adjacent items with the same
category.  For the two ski trips
play lists, we can annotate with
play lists and Android Auto will
add them for you.
We're also adding some
additional annotations on media
items that would be really
useful on our trip.  I might be
heading out to the mountains
with my family, I might worry
about a song coming up with
explicit content.  We are able
to say this has exlicit content
and Android Auto can show that
in the UI.  I might not have
great bandwidth, I'd love to
know if they've been downloaded
or maybe I don't want to burn my
data on music that I'm playing.
We can also annotate with
whether or not media items have
been downloaded and are already
on the device.
Great.  Looks like the ski trip
2018 is downloaded, doesn't have
any explicit content, great
choice for my trip out to the
mountains.
There's one more function that
needed updating, the media
browser service is called when a
media app is first connected to
by Android Auto.  In order for
search, you'll need to add a
couple of extras to let Android
Auto know you support those
features.  As I mentioned, we're
introducing consent styling and
Android Auto will be
interpreting it in a much more
visually pleasing way.  Folders
will be interpreted as lists.
But for playable items, things
like songs or albums or play
lists, we're going to be showing
them now as grids.  Most of
thesethese items have richer
content that users can identify
by seeing much easier than
reading and much safer when
you're in the car.
There are times when a list is
better than a grid.  For
example, in a podcast app, each
of the individual podcasts would
have individual art that is much
more visually representative
while the episodes, instead,
they'd have all the same art but
different episode titles and
lengths and status and it would
be much better to show them as
lists.
In the
ongetroute function, they can
say, I prefer them to be grids.
My playable items to be lists.
Or vice versa.  They have full
control over how we're slowing
the items.
I already mentioned the
universal media player.  I just
want to reiterate, it's a great,
comprehensive media app.  It
gaves you implementation of a
media app that actually plays
music and it's for Android Auto
as well as Wear and Android TV.
I encourage you to check out the
Android media controller,
another open source on GitHub.
It will connect to your app's
session and shows you
information in a clear, semantic
format.  If you're using
whitelisting, it would probably
be a good idea to add the white
list.
So to sum up, we've shown code
samples for MessagingStyle,
actions, attaching new extras
for media items metadata and
declaring support for content
browse and search.
So, great.  We look forward to
seeing all of your messaging and
media apps in the car.  Rasekh
and I will be available tomorrow
morning at office hours to
answer any questions you have
about Android Auto.
Thank you so much for
watching.
[Applause]
Hi, everyone.  Thank you for
coming and watching my session,
which is going to be Android on
large screens.  Just waiting for
it to pop
up.  Cool.  So as we all know,
Android has evolved from just
being a phone platform.  It's
available on watches and cars,
as we just heard.  Desktop,
phones and specifically the
mobile space has already changed
drastically.
Let's see what your mobile is
running on today.
Starting on the phone, it's what
we all develop for mainly.  A
couple keys about the platform,
portrait-first, touch-first and
full-screen first.  A lot of
apps lock rotation.  Some users
use multi-window or styles and
things like that.  Majority of
your users are using it with
regular touchscreens and in full
screen.  Moving on to tablets.
Both oriantsations are
first-class citizens.  If you
lock a portrait, users can still
use your app in the portrait
landscape.  Larger screens do
bring challenges, design-wise,
and the ability to do different
things and take more advantage
of the real estate and allow
your users to do things faster.
The different medium brings a
different focus on what apps are
going to be used for, content
apps or media consumption apps,
productivity apps, things that
can really take advantage of the
larger screen.
And then moving on to kind of
the desktop platforms.  You
know, we have Chromeless, we
have
OEMs.  Also, Android has now
brought the ability to take
advantage of having external
displays.  Even if it's running
on a phone, it could be
displayed to an external
monitor.  This is where the
biggest difference comes in
where it 's landscape first, all
these environments have some
sort of window resizes and you
have new first-class input
methods such as keyboard and
mouse and track pads that shift
with the device or will be
connected.
So, what's a focus on when
you're thinking about how to
bring your apps to all these
platforms and have a good user
experience?  Number one is
design.  Again, if you've really
been focusing on phones, most of
your designs are very
portrait-based and
smaller-screen based.  Window
management is probably the
biggest place where we see
issues with partners apps,
dealing with resizing,
multi-window consideration or
problems we've never had to
focus on before.
We're going to talk about the
tooling available from Google to
make sure you're able to develop
for these platforms and bring it
into your actual cycle.
So, talking about design, raise
your hands if you have layouts
for large screens or lablets at
all?  A lot more people than I
expected.  Cool.  So, you know,
biggest thing is just thinking
about largest screens again.
For the last couple of years,
we've seen a lot more apps come
out that might lock to portrait,
which makes sense.  With a more
-- more and more growing number
of platforms that are running
your APK, but showing a
different form factor or
platform, it's time to start
thinking again about how to
bring the best experience to
those areas.
A really bad example of design
is Google Play Music, which is
always great.  A couple things
about this that are not great,
super-stretched layout, tons of
space that could be used for
descriptions.  The biggest key
here, though, is there's no line
dividers, which on a phone is
fine because see what options
menu you're clicking on.  When
you take it to a larger
landscape layout, it's hard to
follow the lines and see what
item you're pressing the options
menu for.
An external partner is One
Passward.  It's your standard
list of items you'll drill down
into.  When you move to a larger
screen, they really take
advantage of the real estate
going to almost like a
three-panel layout, allowing the
user to get whatever content
they need in a lot less clicks
and a lot faster.  Also, being
able to showcase more
information at the same time.
So, kind of going back to the
same point is, again, building
layouts for both orientations
and there's a couple big keys
for this.  Again, not all
platforms are portrait-first.  A
lot of the desktop environments,
if you're building for portrait,
you're going to have a pretty
bad user experience when I want
to use your app in full screen
or the top-half of the screen.
On top of that, resizing
capabilities allow the user to
make your app whatever size
orientation or screen ratio that
they really want to.  So, you
really want to let the user
really decide how they want to
use your app.
Going back to kind of mainly the
desktop platforms is designing
for mediums other than touch.
Take into consideration how your
app works with a mouse or
stylus.  The UX patterns are
different for touch than
non-touch.  Things like
right-clicking are different
than what we're used to with
long-pressing.  Whereas when you
right-click on a desktop, you're
usually expecting a pop-up
context menu.  So, taking the
time to really think about how
your app works for the different
UX considerations.
The other big one we noticed is
hover actions.  On the web or
desktop environments with the
mouse, you expect some type of
feedback when you move your
mouse over an action item to let
you know there is something you
can do there, whether it's
clickable or dragbable.  There's
some feedback.  Myself, even if
I use the app on a phone,
extensively, Google Drive is a
good example of this, Android on
Chrome OS, I'll miss actions
that I can actually do because
just navtly on this platform,
I'm expecting hover actions.
I'm going to go over two simple
APIs.  There are many APIs that
help handle a lot of these input
methods and things such as mouse
scrolling and things and there
will be resources when the
slides get posted.
Right-clicking, which is one of
the feature blocks, is super
easy.  You make sure you're exes
posing whatever behavior you
have on long-press.  Again, also
hopefully considering any type
of UX changes you need to make.
And setting a hover listening to
watch for the user's pointer
hovering over the item and out.
Again, this is really the
biggest one we see that will
lead to misfunctionality or
really give you the desktop
native feel or even kind of the
large-screen native feel.
In terms of hovering, most of
our native components do handle
this. The contrast and change
may not be enough for you or
your users or especially
accessibility things like that.
At the end of the day, though,
you know how your users use the
app and you know the product so,
you know, take some time and use
your app on different platforms
and think about how you'd expect
the app to behave.  It might not
need to focus on mouse input or
keyboard input.  Where a
productivity app is going to
take advantage of the screen
real estate and find a way for
users to do what they want to.
Talking about window management.
This is the biggest area we see
challenges.  I love rotation
because I see so many apps that
lock to portrait, which is
completely understandbable but
it really shows where the
experience falls.  If you do
lock portrait on Chrome OS, this
is what your app will look like.
You'll get these super black
bars on the side and it's wasted
screen real estate.  It gives a
non-native [no audio].
Now, why do we -- to run away
from handleing configuration
changes because they've always
been rather difficult to deal
with.  Configuration changes are
more important than ever.
Resizing and multi-window brings
a lot of new configuration
change paradigms and challenges.
Chrome OS is probomy one of the
most complex of the resizing
strategies because it does
trigger configuration changes
pretty frequently.  I know some
of the other desktop platforms
don't cause as many
configuration changes.  On top
of that, with bigger screens,
multi-window is going to be used
much more frequently.
This is a quick thing about how
resizing on Chrome OS works.
Anytime one of those labels
changes, it's going through a
complete destroy and rebuild
process.  So you can imagine
that this can get triggered
substantially faster and
substantially more often than on
a phone.
Jetpack helps with this.  The
things like ViewModel and being
able to build your own
components allows you to take
your business logic in your
activity, anything you're doing
to save state so your activity
destroy and rebuild process is
really quick.
Your app will not always be in
focus.  Again, this isn't new.
With Android N, we brought
multi-window.  I know most of us
that work with a large monitor
have multiple things up at once
and you need to make sure that
your content is visible and
playing.  So make sure that
you're still displaying
messaging or your content
continues to play.
Take advantage of the features.
Larger screens and external
monitors bring new
possibilities.  One of the
things we've seen some of the
apps do, that really kind of
bring a better experience, is
allowing -- email compose
windows or new documents being
shown in different tasks so the
user can see their email, plus
this new email they're creating
in a different window.
Something that we released quite
a bit ago, but is now being a
lot more is drag and drop.
Again, these desktop platforms
specifically, users expect drag
and drop to be a thing.  So,
think about if drag and drop
kind of makes sense in your app
and how you can kind of bring it
to these platforms.
And then not really window
management, but different
features that are kind of new to
these ecosystems is different
info capabilities and
specifically, like, increased
stylus usage.  The biggest thing
that we've seen that users have
loved is the ability to have
keyboard shortcuts and keyboard
navigation so if there are
things they use often, they are
able to do things faster, get in
and out of the app and get it
done as quick as possible.
So, this is great and all but
how do we actually build for
this?  Moving on to tooling, you
know, it would be awful if I
came up here and talked about,
you should do all these things
yet there are no tools to make
this possible.  Most of the
tooling devices that we do --
tooling examples we do have are
around Chrome OS.  A, it's our
platform and, B, it's the
platform we have.  Most devices
ship with a keyboard intrack.
Some don't have a touchscreen.
So, it's kind of the best all in
one platform to test on.  We're
working on bringing some
integration around larger
screens in Chrome OS.  Lint
additions are coming soon.  It's
my job, once this event's over,
to finish this.  We're look ing
at more things we can bring to
the ide.  It's great to have
devices you can test on, but we
want to be able to give quicker
feedback and things to look for
while you're actually developing
in the ide.  So if you have
ideas, please come let me know.
There's a Chrome OS emulator
that's currently in preview.  If
you don't have devices, you can
download the emulator and start
to see where your app falls
apart.  Things that don't work.
Things that crash.  You know, et
cetera.
One of the biggest complaints
for developer for Chrome OS and
testing has been having to use
ADB over WiFi and development
cycle's been crappy.  On the HP
Chromebook and Pixelbook, you
can bring the devices into the
same development cycle you do
with phones.  We hope to bring
more and more -- more and more
devices to this feature.
But the easiest way, really, is
just to run Android Studio on
Chrome OS.  This is available on
the Pixelbook on preview and
we're hoping to bring it to more
devices thin future. This is on
the Android Chrome OS table.  To
be able to build the app and
deploy directly to the device
makes the whole
development cycle substantially
easier and faster.
There's more and more platforms
that are running APKs, whether
they're different flavors or
mobile APK.  So make sure your
app is, too.
Thank you.  Again, please ask
any questions, any suggestions
that you have for tooling, any
things you've ran into when
trying to develop for larger
screen platforms, I would love
to hear about so that we can
tackle this.  Thank you.
[Applause]
All right.  So, I just want to
let everyone know.  It is
currently snack time.  So, we
have snacks [no
audio]
.
All you have to do is use the
right plugin.  You have the base
function and then you apply the
application plugin, which you
have used for years.  You can
apply the dynamic feature.  Now,
we have to declare a special
dependency from the base module
to all of the different feature
and I will explain to you later
why this is necessary.
Obviously, you have a dependency
from the module to the base, but
you need to make dependency from
the base to the futures.  So, as
an example here, we've got the
flow.  You have a base module
and three modules.  Nothing too
specific.  It depends on the
base.
Now, by adding the DSL
declaration, we're declaring
that the module A, B And c are
future models.  We have this
dependency going both ways.
So, when we go through the build
flow, the first thing that we do
is that we build normally all
the files into classes.  That's
normal.  That's the normal
process that we go through when
we build each of these different
modules.  The thing that really
starts to differ is we are
publishing back all of this job
files back to the main module
and that's absolutely module
because you need to have a
global view of the application.
You can't do a shrinking on the
future module because you will
not know how and what the class
is.
So, once you have those
published to the basis, you can
feed it to the shrinker and it
will create equivalent text
files.  There is a one-to-one
method.  But, it's not exactly a
1:1.  Let's say you had classes
that were in your base module
that you thought would be shared
by different features but used
used by module B, but the
splitter can move that instead
of keeping them inside the main
dexter jar of the main module.
Otherwise, you can more or less
imagine there's a 1:1.  You have
all these text files still
residing in the base module, now
they're going to flow back into
the
originated module.  We do that
so we can have -- as you can
see, at the beginning, we
had compilation, it was
paralyzed.  If you have a
powerful machine, they run in
parallel and it becomes a
bottleneck because it has to
wait for all the modules to be
ready to do the shrinking and
then we can move back the
processing to each of the same
modules.
So, you can see that adding
modularity to your application
might be a good self-practice.
We're going to get much faster
of a time.  We move as much as
we can and we can run all of
those in parallel as much as
possible.
Once this is done in parallel --
one this is pushed back to each
feature module, we can
eventually create all the
necessarily APKs or artifacts.
All of those, again, are in
parallel.  The shrinker is
usually not a problem because --
not a problem because usually
people do not use shrinker
during the builds.  But we
really try to limit this
bottlenecks as much as we can
and how we have enhanced the
processing with this type of
improvements.
Another thing that we did was
D8, that's a new JVM bind codes
translator.  We will essentially
remove the old one, which is DX.
If you are using DX, you need to
start panicking because we are
going to remove it.  So if you
are using DX because you issues
with D8, you must follow through
to figure what's wrong.
Otherwise you're going to get
stuck in the past.  R8 is going
to follow the path.  It's
available now to try.  We are
very happy with the results we
are getting so far, so it's very
stable.  You should definitely
try it.  Eventually it'll become
stable and you can guess what's
going to happen to the old code
shrinker, eventually we will
remove it and replace it with
R8.  There is a session tomorrow
that will give you more
technical details about how
these two libraries are
implemented.
Okay.  Let's talk a little bit
about what's next in 3.3.  So,
the first thing I want to talk
about is tasks.  The concept of
task -- lazy task is -- you
should really understand it as a
task that will only get
initialized if it's on thee
excuse. You've got two variant.
If you debug, there's no need to
initialize the task.  So, what
we used to do, unfortunately --
so this was done before in this
particular example where we used
to create all the tasks.  We
still have to do that.  But add
the creation time, we're also
configuring them.  So we're
configuring all of them.
With task, we have the tool to
delay of the initialization
until it knows that those tangs
with executed.  What it means is
that it's going to be up-to-date
checked.  Meaning, it's going to
look if the task needs to run or
not by running its up-to-date
checks.  Maybe executed if it's
out of date.
So, how to you do lazy tasks?
It's basically similar to the
old style, but you can see that
now the configuration code,
which is in blue here, will only
be called if the task is on the
execution task graph.  Now we
used to pay a lot of attention
to all of our configuration
tasks, to make this
configuration block as lean as
possible because they were
always executed.  So we tried to
keep it as lean as possible with
no access to disk, no access to
network, for instance.
Now, it's probably a little bit
more okay to do more work in
those configuration if you
really have to, but you have to
remember two things.  First, if
you do real work, it will still
impact your build time because
the configuration time is still
a thread event.  All of the
configuration will happen the
one after the other.  The more
you do, the longer it will take.
Configuration time happens all
the time.  It's very anowing.
The second thing is to not look
up tasks anymore.  So when you
have customization -- a lot of
people are doing project, get
task by name.  Stuff like that.
This will actually look up the
task and  and initialize it. It
will do that and all the
dependancies as well, all the
tasks and output so you
basically have a good chance of
initializing it.  Instead of
doing that, you should get a
provider and get a lazy object
of the task itself and use that
to register your dependency.
Now, what you can also do, if
you want to have access to the
output of a task, is use that
provider and map the output
using the start of API to get
provider so it's basically a
promise on the folder or a
promise of a regular file that
the task that executes will give
you it later.  You can get an
object, that object does not
initial ize the task itself.
Getting this provider does not
initialize the task, does not
force it to run and it's really
lazy.  It contains dependency
and information which means you
don't have to register yourself
as a dependence of the task.
Holding the object will allow
you to not only get the object,
but also register your
dependency. Eventually, you can
do a get and that will get you
the object you can use.
So, here when it is getting
configured, all the dependancy
will get configured and so on
and so forth.  We are
retrofitting all of our tasks
using providers and stuff like
that.  If you use customization
a lot, you need to look into
these APIs in 3.3.
And now Chris will talk about
other improvements we have made.
Yes.  Another optimization is
classes.  Previously, for every
single dependency and every
subject, and alongside your
actual classes.  It just
generates a jar containing the
class directly.  And especially
for those with many libraries
and lots of dependencys, this
avoided a lot of compilation.
For large multi-modal builds, we
saw a large percentage of
speed-ups.
So the class system has been
rewritten.  Rather than relying
on the ones on disk.  It
actually speeds up indexing in
Android Studio, as well.  Even
for older Gradle plugins.  This
does, however, break some Gradle
plugins, including Butter Knife.
It is in library device in 3.3.
Gradle now has supports
for annotation processing.
We're working to support the
most popular annotation
processes, including dagger,
Room, Gride.
And to allow to be an isolated
annotation processor, speeding
it up even more.  We also want
to help you understand that
build time impact of annotation
processes.  We want to report to
you, like, which -- time spent
in and how much did they cost?
On that theme, there are several
other areas we want to give you
better insight into your build,
easily and simply.  If you're
using annotation processes, it's
really critical you have that
insight because it's often a
bottleneck for a lot of builds
we see.  When a task causes you
trouble, it's great to know the
Gradle plugin or the script and
what triggered it to run.  And
we're working to make finding
that out more easily.
We also want to help you find
these types of issues, even if
you're not actively looking for
them.  Longer-term,
we want Android Studio to flag
if there is an issue and point
you toward the greater build
scan.
Okay.  So, on from these better
insights to complete rewrites.
Android resource namespacing.
Resource namespacing is a
completely new pipeline for
compiling and linking Android
resources.  We're doing this for
two reasons.  Firstly, speed up
the build and make it easier to
understand and we want better
support dynamic features.
Looking at how thingessess work
now, there are two namespaces.
That means if you have two
libraries, the same name and the
same type, they have to pick one
and it's not always clear what
the right thing to do is.  It
makes splitting your APK much
more difficult.  Where those
resources come from and where
they go is really important.
Each library is compiled and
linked separately and then
linked together in the final
APK.  When you're using
resources from both XML and
Java, you need to be explicit
about where they came from.  If
they're in the library that
defined it, the next XML, you
need to use the name space.
This also means they no longer
override each other just because
they have the same name.  When
you need overrides, we're
working on a new way to do that
explicitly.
ARs will be backwards compatible
so you can have all the benefits
of namespacing.
Okay.  Passing on to Izabela to
tell you a little bit more about
the details.
Thank you.  Now that we know
what namespacing is, you might
find yourself asking your
questions like, where is that
resource coming from or what is
the proper syntax?  Or, how do I
even namespace my dependancies?
The answer to all these
questions is, we'll fix it for
you.
[Laughter]
So, yes, so the solution is
automatic namespacing or auto
namespacing for sure.  First is
the oughtmotic rewriting tool in
the ideal.  And the second one
are the transforms and tasks in
the Gradle plugin that will
rewrite your remote
dependancies, under the hood, no
action required.
Here is an example of a
dependency graph.  The blue
nodes are local modules that can
be rewritten using the ide tool.
The three orange nodes are not
namespaced, classic remote
libraries that will be
automatically rewritten.  All
the resources, classes, the
manifests will be rewritten to
use the full resource namespace.
And finally, the green nodes are
-- they represent dependancies
that are already namespaced so
they will not be modified at
all.
Let's see what types of changes
we can see after this migration
takes place.  In the bytecode,
you can see that now there will
be different classes present.
If a resource was defined in a
different module or remote
library, you'll see the package
of the class change to match
that package.  In the
On-Device  -- XML resources,
you'll see it at the @ symbol.
And finally, another way
resources can be referenced is
in attributes, for example, in
layouts.  Here, it will be
modified to point and the
attribute will use this new
namespace, as well.  Since we're
on the topic of resources, let's
talk about visibility.  Probably
many of you created an Android
library with a lot of effort
declaring which resources are
public and published this with a
.txt only for consumers to
ignore it.  This currently is
only a Lint warning.  This code
compiles and runs fine at
runtime, completely ignoring the
intended visibility of the
resource.  I'm sure many of you
actually ignored these warnings,
as well.
We want to introduce visibility.
So, these violations will now
become build errors instead so
we'll catch them early and three
levels of visibility.  One,
public.  This means these
resources will be present both
in the public classes and the
private classes for that local
module.
Private resources, only present
in private classes and last,
private XML-only resources. They
will not be present any classes
at all.  Instead, you can only
reference them from other XML
files within that module.
This will result in smaller
classes, both compile and
runtime.  And, also, resource
similar to the class or
method in Kotlin.
Thank you.
[Applause]
All right.  So, as you can
see, we're working on a lot of
things and many of which we hope
would help build speed.  Going
back to my point around
awareness and tooling, I wanted
to share some things you can do
today to understand your build
better and improve its
performances.  So, the first
things is to upgrade.  My first
graph, we do improve with every
release and so if you're really
-- care about your build speed,
the best thing to do is upgrade
to the latest beta, stable,
Canary, whatever you feel
comfortable with.
There are some tools you can
start leverages to
better-understand your builds.
One that I really like is a free
tool from Gradle.  It implodes
some of your data into Gradle
servers and provides dashboards.
If you're trying to understand
what's going on with your build,
why is it slow, this is a very,
very useful resource to use.
If sharing some of your build
data with Gradle is something
you don't feel comfortable with,
there's--profile.  Definitely
not as rich, but it provides
some information and it remains
local.  You can combine it
with--info which gives you
information on a given task.
Another tip is file bug.  We
try to test all of our releases
on any environment and use cases
we can, but there's aways
different configurations out
there.  Please file bugs when
you encounter issues.  Please
include a scan with it.  It
really helps us go deeper into
the issue and understand what's
going on.
Last, but not least, if you're
writing plugins, whether it's
for you to publish them or
customize a little bit, your
build file, here's a set of tips
to follow.  So, first, as Jerome
eluded to, it is to set up
tasks, not really do anything
else.  Remember, if you need to
compute things for up-to-date
checks, you can always use
provider and suppliers to always
run those checks if your task is
part of the active graph.
For example, in configuration,
you should not do things like
query get, read a file, search
for a connected device or
compute anything.  Configuration
is really just a place to set up
tasks.  And it's a place to set
up all tasks.  Because build
doesn't really know what pass is
going to take in events so try
to set up all of your tasks in
the configuration step.
Regarding task s, make sure that
each task's declared all input
and outputs, even if it's
non-file one and make sure
they're incremental and
cacheable.
If your were working with a
complex step, try to split it
into multiple tasks.  This helps
with the incrementtality because
some tasks could be up-to-date.
If you have multiple tasks, they
could run in parallel.  So it
helps with incrementality and
parallelism.
This third best-practice sounds
obviously, but I still want to
put it out there.  Make sure
they don't write into or delete
any other task output.
When you write tasks, use Java
and Kotlin.  And put them in a
plugin/folder.
And last, but not least, as
you've heard from Jerome,
leverage a new worker API -- no,
we didn't talk about this.
I did talk about stuff though.
That really helps with
problems.  If you didn't get
clear pictures of all of what I
just said, don't worry.  We're
working on a full write-up
covering everything that we
talked about around speed,
around the findings that I
shared, the tooling and the best
practices and more, so, stay
tuned.
To recap, here's the takeaway
from this session.  First, we
shared some finding on speed and
that basically a little bit
outpaced by some of the
features, the plugins and all
the other things but we're
taking this very seriously so
we're doubling-down or efforts
on better tooling and
attribution and continuing to
improve performances.
We share the new features in 3.2
and I definitely encourage you
to upgrade to 3.2, if you
haven't already.
And we mentioned some of the
things that were working for 3.3
and beyond.  3.3 beta is
available. So, I encourage you
to try it.  It has some of the
things we mentioned, like lazy
tasks and others.
And last, I talked about some of
the tools that you can use -- --
profile.
That's it for today.  I want to
make a bad joke, but unlike
build, we finished earlier than
expected.  We're going to be out
there with -- in the speaker Q&A
or at the studio booths today
and tomorrow, if you have any
questions.
So, thank you.
[Applause]
Everyone, the next session, in
this room, will begin at 4:50.
Thank you,
everyone.
Thank you, everyone.
Welcome back, everyone.  As a
point of information, this
session will get under way in
two minutes.  And we ask you, as
a courtesy to the presenters, to
take a moment to silent your
phones and digital devices.  We
thank everyone.  Come on in and
be seated.  Our program will get
under way in two minutes.
Hello.  Good afternoon.  I'm
super excited to be here and
today, we're going to be talking
about ConstraintLayout and how
to use the visual editor to
effectively make constraints in
Android Studio.
I'm Chris, UX designer and
I'll be talking about some of
the new features we've added.
And I'm Sean McQuillan,
developer advocate for Android.
After we talk about the basics
in 1.0-1.1, we'll talk about
some of the constraints.
When I add a view to a
ConstraintLayout in the editor,
I'll have one in the top, left,
right and bottom.  If I go to
the view inspector, I'm going to
add a constraints to view.  In
ConstraintLayout, before I added
this constraints, it will lay it
out somewhere in the screen.
It's 30DP and I have
fully-constrained this view and
now ConstraintLayout knows how
to solve where this goes.  We'll
start with a simple example how
to build up more
complex examples of constraints.
I would change this to be
50DP or add a constraint to the
side.
If I add another to the bottom,
I'm going to center this view on
the entire ConstraintLayout and
this trick is going to work
everywhere in ConstraintLayout.
This is how you center a view
inside or on top of another
view.
So, let's take a look at one
more thing I can do.  So, if I
look at the slider that's over
on the left.  It starts at 50
when I've constrained the top
and bottom and I can change
that.  I can change it up to 25.
Instead of centering, it will
introduce the bias to the
layout.  It's going to lay that
out 25% along the way, 75% along
the way and a horizontal slider,
as well.
So, let's dive in further into
this view inspector and take a
look at what's available in the
special editor.  There's this
triple chev going on.  John said
it's because it's wrapped
content and it's trying to pull
in as hard as it can from both
sides.  I can change it to fixed
width.  That's
100DP.  So match constraints is
a new feature, a new way to lay
out views.  Take out all of the
views available.
I'm constrained off the right
and the left so it's the same
thing as full parent.  This is
how you would take up the whole
screen.  You wouldn't want to
use full parent in
ConstraintLayout.  I get this
really interesting icon here.  I
thought this was a heartbeat,
for the longest time.  I asked
John about this.  That's
actually a spring and on some
versions of Android Studio, you
get two springs and on others,
you get one.
So, let's switch this back over
to wrap content and add another
view so we can start building
more complex layouts.  I'm going
to add an image view and
constrain it so it's
20DP.  It's going to move the
image view so it's 20DP.  I'm
going to add another constraint
and the image view is going to
center itself.
We can do this on another view,
as well.
Now, I want to change the width
of this view from wrap content
to match constraints.  And this
time, instead of match
constraints, it's going to take
the width of this text view,
whatever size this text view, it
will try to match that
constraint and this new control
shows up.  This little line, it
creates a little triangle.  I
enable an aspect ratio.  This is
a really nice feature, if you
want to display an image with an
aspect ratio.  Images, when we
get them from designers, they
want 1-by-1.  You're laughing
because you're a designer.
It's my fault.  Sorry.
[Laughter]
We can set up exactly what our
designers want for and resize
this view as the text changes
while maintaining this aspect
ratio.  If I set it to 3:1, I
set one aspect ratio that says,
I'd like to this to be one
constraint, 3:1.  And another
saying this can be no wider than
this text box.  ConstraintLayout
has to solve this and it will
use the contraints from the text
box.
I can free up another dimension.
So if I change the height to be
match constraints, it's capable
of resizing both dimensions so
now it can set the 3:1 aspect
ratio.  So, that's all we can do
with just a single, you know
element or two elements.  Let's
add more of a complex view and
talk about how to lay things out
with more features with
ConstraintLayout.
My designer sent me this lovely
email form.  This is talk about
ConstraintLayout and not Login
forms.  Don't copy this, there's
many problems.  There's a couple
things going on.  The labels are
right-aligned to some sort of
invisible line.  The edit text
is left-aligned and the Login
and new account button are
hanging off and there appears to
be a line.
And then at the same time, email
and password are vertically
centered on the screen.  How are
we going to lay out those, you
know, text views?  We have the
email text and the email edit
text.  We could align the top of
the text view to the top.  That
would be incorrect.  If we look
at font metrics, we have this
baseline at the bottom.  In
English and most languages,
almost everything sits on and
the ascender line and that
dashed line is the descends
descender line.
This creates a single line of
text for our eyes and allows us
to read it as a cohairants unit
so we want to do that in
ConstraintLayout.  I'm going to
get this control.  It looks like
this, I've enlarged it
substantially.  I get my
favorite control.  It blinks in
the editor, I call it the
green-glowing orb of baseline.
We can go to the edit text and
drag from one baseline to the
other and create a constraint
saying these text views should
have the same baseline.  And
we'll do that for all the other
text views on the screen here in
order to set up all the baseline
alignments.
When you line up text next to
text, you almost always want to
use the baseline.  That's the
correct way to do that in
ConstraintLayout.  Let's put
that Login button on the screen.
It has to be constrained on the
left edit text.  How to do this
centering, the email and
password is vertically centered
on the screen.  How am I going
to do that?  We put a constraint
on both side of the screen and
centers.  I'll put it from email
to the top of the screen.  From
password from the bottom of the
screen and so far, this makes
sense.
Now, I guess I'm going to have
to add a constraint from
password to email.  So, I'm
going to do that and this is
going to center password between
email and the bottom of the
screen.  Let's pull email back
down with another constraint and
I'll solve this problem.  This
introduces a chain.
Now of course, setting up all
the constraints is tedious.  You
can go into right-click on
center and choose vertically.
When I have email and password
selected, it's going to set up
all of the constraints that I
just talked about.  So, inside
of a chain, there's actually
three different ways it can get
laid out -- four, technically.
We have spread, which means
evenly distribute everything.
Spread inside, which is
basically the same thing except
the first and last elements get
pushed to the side.  Then we
have pack.  We're going to use a
packed chain to center these
views together.  There's one
more thing we need to do.  We
need to put this invisible line
in the middle of the screen.  So
to do that, I'm going to go to
helpers and add a vertical
guideline.  You can think of it
as a new edge of the screen.  I
have one on the left and now I
put an edge of the screen in the
middle of the screen I can use
as an anchor for constraints.  I
take the text views and create
constraints from those.  To kind
of visualize what this is doing
underneath, if I move the
guideline, it's actually going
to move the entire layout now.
So, let's move that back and
then let's get another design
because it turned out that
design was not performing very
well.  After many user studies,
we've discovered the solution is
left-aligning the labels.  So,
let's try to do that.  Well, I
did it and I translated it to
German and this is what
happened.  This is not great.
So, what happened here?  So, it
turns out, if I lay this out
similar to the way I just did,
so, password's the longest field
in these labels so if I set up a
constraint and another
constraint from edit text down
to the password edit text, this
is going to work great in
English.  When I translate it to
German, it is no longer correct.
So what I'm going to need is
something that's dynamic, that's
based on all these things.  Kind
of like a view group.
Basically, I might want a linear
layout.  I'm in
ConstraintLayout, so how do I do
that in ConstraintLayout?
There's another helper and we're
going to use that now.  If we
use add vertical barrier, this
allows you to add a barrier to
the screen.  It is like a view
group.  It's a grouping code.
We can open up the componentry
and add it.  It's a view that's
added to the screen.  It's
positioned on one side or the
other of all of the views that
are inside of it.  By default,
it's on the left.  If I open the
attributes  pane, I can set it
up to the end.
I will set up the constraints
and translate my English into
German.  So, that's really it.
That's all of the features in
ConstraintLayout 1.0 and 1.1.
So Chris is going to talk about
more tricks that can be used to
use the visual editor to build
constraints.
Cool.  Thanks, Sean.  So, with
constraint layout, we've
introduced many consents. We
started with constraintss,
margins and chains.  We've
introduced guidelines and
barriers and groups and many
more helpers to come and there's
motion layout.  One thing that
we've heard consistently is that
as we've added more concepts,
it's becoming increasingly
harder to manage all of these
with ConstraintLayout.
And so, what I'm here to tell
you, today, is that we've
actually been improving this in
the visual editor in Android
Studio.  The four areas are
creating constraints, and new
view and tricks on zooming and
panning and then of course,
using sample data, which we
introduced back in 3.2.
So creating constraints, in this
case, we have two components.
An image view and a text view.
If we want to center the image
view, we put one constraint on
the top and one of there bottom.
Let's take that lovely Login
form from below.  We have
labels, we have inputs, some
buttons.  But from the
constraint point of view, we
have this guideline in the
middle, the Login button
constrained to the bottom and
right of the input.  We have the
inputs constrained to the
guideline.  Because they are all
pretty close to each other, when
you're dragging these around, it
can be pretty challening to get
it right.
Even when I made that slide, I
hid half the constraints because
it was too busy.
Yeah, it was very simplified,
actually.
We've added the ability to add
constraints directly with the
context menu.  If you have
components that are really close
to each other, this makes it a
lot more precise and direct to
set those constraints.  So, in
this case -- and this is
available in 3.3 beta, as well,
so you can try it out today.
And so, in this case, we have
this lovely cat picture.  You
can just simply constrain it to
the parent.  So, what does it
look like if you have multiple
components?  So, in this case,
we have these two text views
that are really close to each
other and so I'm not sure if
people have tried to create it,
it becomes painful when you're
going from the bottom of one to
the top of the other.  You can
keep the two selected, and then
when you open up the context
menu, there's this constraint
menu and you can see the two
elements you want to use are
there and then you can easily
cascade to the right constraint
that you want.
In this case, we're only showing
the start and end and that's
because, in this case, the top
and bottom constraints have
already been set so we don't
show them.
So, here, we want to constrain
the location icon to this
vertical guideline on the left.
So, if you use the drag and drop
method, you get all these --
Sean's favorite green flashing
stuff.  If you're trying to
target some of these smaller
things like the following text
or numbers, it gets hard when
you're trying to do drag and
drop.  Again, this makes a lot
more direct so you can select
the guideline and use the
context menu.
If you really don't want to
select these things, you can use
the component tree.  This
becomes useful.  It does the
exact same thing.
But if you do like drag and
drop, you know, you can still do
it and one thing that we've
tried to make easier is actually
when you drag it and so in this
case, we have this new gesture
which, pending, is called drag
to center.  As you drag, you now
see all these little targets and
so instead of trying to actually
target those specific green
dots, you can simply drag to the
middle of the thing you want to
constrain to.
In this case, if I drag from the
Mountain View text view, I can
drag to the cat picture and get
a pop-up menu that shows me the
two constraints I can set.
Because we're going from the
left of the mountain view text
view to the cat picture, the two
constraints are the left and
right.
And we actually have this, as
well, which comes in handy when
you have overlapping views and
so this one's pretty simple but
sometimes you have views you
want to hide and show at runtime
and so all you have to do is
drag to wherever -- to the
target and what we'll do is
actually figure out which fews
are under the pixel and show you
a context menu accordingly.
So, if we move on to view
options, so, the design surface
has always had view options to
take advantage of when you're
working with your layouts.  The
two are show all constraints and
live rendering.  So, if we go
back to our Login form, we're
going to reuse this a lot.
[Laughter]
You know, the constraints are
set here.  But the thing is,
when you're trying to -- let's
say you're new to this layout
and you're trying to edit
constraints on one of these
controls, there is a lot going
on.  And this is simplified
compared to the normal design
surface.  And so what we've
3.3 is added this option to show
all constraints but it's turned
off by default.  What we'll do
is we only show the constraints
on the actively-selected
component.  It makes it easier
to work with the component
you're working with.
Of course, you can easily turn
this back on if you do want to
see all the constraints at the
same time.
And so this is kind of showing
you a side-by-side.  On the
left, we have it turned off.  On
the right, we have it turned on.
Especially in the design surface
or design mode, it cleans it up
a lot because you don't have
arrows and margin, especially
for the 322 and following and
the 20 followers.  Blueprint
mode is the same thing.  Even
though blueprint mode is heavily
simplified, it still gets a
little hairy to look at.  And
so, we think this is a good
option, as well, here The other
view option we have is live
rendering, we've done live
rendering for quite some time.
Let me go back.  Can I go back?
Oh.  And so, it's on by default
but depending on the specs of
your machine, it can be slow.
You might make a mistake.  Often
times when I've tried to use it,
I've tried to create a
constraint and the button will
move after it and that causes me
to make more mistakes.  And so
if you turn it off, it's much
faster as you drag and move
things around.  You can still
see the bounding boxes and so
you'll know where things end up.
The only downside is it doesn't
render as you drag
Alternatively, you can use
blueprint mode.  Here, we don't
do any live renderings.  This is
the best way to work with
ConstraintLayout because you can
focus on the constraints So to
set these options, they're in
the top-left corner and if you
want to switch, that is using
the blue layers icon, as well.
Zooming and panning.  So, you've
actually been able to zoom and
pan in the lab editor and it
comes really in handy when
you're dealing with
ConstraintLayout when things are
really small or close to each
other or overlapping.  What
we've done, in 3.3, is changed
the keyboard shortcuts to match
more from Photo Shop and Sketch.
You can use command or control
and then the equal
[no audio].
So, it's command and control and
then command and control with
the mouse and pinch in the
opposite direction.  And then
zoom to fit, so if you're zoomed
in and you want to get back to
that layout, you can use command
and control, plus zero.
And so then, if you're zoomed in
and you don't actually want to
zoom out, but you want to pan
around, you can actually do so
by holding space and using the
mouse to click and drag.  This
is kind of a familiar gesture if
you've used Photo Shop or other
design tools.
And so the last tip is using
sample data and so with sample
data, in ConstraintLayout, it's
easier to preview how your
layouts will respond to
different content types at
runtime and so we introduced
sample data helpers to make it
easier to work within the design
surface.  Specifically for image
views, text views and
recycler views.
And so with the image view, we
have two sample sets.  We have
avatars and scenic backgrounds.
And so if you -- and if you want
to add your own images to the
sample data, you can do so.  You
just create a sample data
directly at the root of your
project.  Sample data, with your
image views constrained, you can
quickly switch between different
types of images and set
different ratios so you can see
how your layout responds without
having to run your app With text
view, we have sample data.  We
have cities.  We have dates,
full names.  If you want your
own sample data, you can create
it at the root of your project
and I think we support flat text
files and JSON.  With text
views, this is more important
because you have text views for
open-ended content.
We have domestic shorthair is a
very short description.  On the
right, this is a bunch of text
plopped in there.  And so, you
know, without having to run our
app, you can see, just with
sample data, how your layout
responds   So, I don't need to
copy lorm ipson off the internet
anymore?
[Laughter]
I think as you mentioned, this
is great for testing out across
different languages.
And so, with that, I'll hand it
back to Sean to talk about some
new features.
Thanks, Chris.  So, that
covers everything in 1.1 and
1.2.  Now I want to move on to
new features coming out in
ConstraintLayout 2.0.  Who has
tried playing with motion editor
already?  So, I see five people.
So, hopefully we can give, like,
a nice introduction here to the
basic concepts and Chris is
going to talk about the design
surface.
So motion layout allows you to
build dynamic layouts using all
the features of ConstraintLayout
we talked about earlier and
changing the constraints over
time.  We see building a
collapsible header that Chris
Banes put together.  So you can
see that title image actually
hides itself behind the view as
it scrolls up.  It's a pretty
dramatic animation.  Before we
get to something like that,
let's talk about what we can
build with MotionLayout, it can
be used to build collapsible
headers, state feedback or
transitions, maybe the open and
closed state of a draw and you
can make most of the animations
in this presentation, as well.
To understand motion and
animation, it's really important
to take a step back and think
about what defines an animation,
not just on Android, but a
Disney movie.  They are defined
by a start and an end.  I start
over here.  I'm here.  And then
I'm ending over here.  And in
betweenbetween, over time, I
created an animation so that's a
very complex motion.  Let's talk
about a simple one.  I'm going
to put a blue dot on the screen
and I'd like to build an
animation.  In order to do that,
I have to define a start.  I
have to define an end.  I'm
going to put that in the bottom
right-corner with constraints
and in order to build a
animation, all I do is
transition from one to the end.
That's what MotionLayout will do
for you.  It'll figure out how
to transition that blue dot from
the start, down to the end.
To build a MotionLayout, you
have to start with a
MotionLayout in your
XML.  We did that so it would
have all the features of
ConstraintLayout.  It points to
a motion scene, which is a
separate XML file and you encode
the start and end information
that defines your animation.
The start and end are defined in
terms of constraint sets.  What
are constraint sets?  You may be
familiar with this already.
What we've been talking about,
so far, is this.  The views, the
actual labels, plus all of the
constraints and all of the
sizing information.  A
constraint set is just this
part.  Just the constraints and
just the sizing information.  It
points to IDs of actual views
but doesn't contain the views.
If I animate a constraint, it
would look like that.  If I
applied it to an animation, it
would look like that.
Let's build a fairly
easy-to-follow-along easy
layout.  Here, we have a pretty
dramatic reveal animation, the
title comes up top, the subtitle
expands down below.  At the same
time, the image in the
background is resizing itself.
So there's a lot of things going
on.  This might actually be hard
to write in code, but it's
fairly easy to write using
MotionLayout.  So, let's take a
look at how we're going to do
that.  To make a MotionLayout,
I'm just going to add -- I'm
going to define the start and
the end.  The start, I'm going
to move the title off the screen
and do that by making a
constraint to the end of the
title to the start of the view
-- to the ConstraintLayout.
ConstraintLayout's very happy to
lay your views out of it, if you
ask it to.
We're also going to do the same
thing on the bottom, where we're
going to put a constraint to
push the description text off
the screen.  Then to actually
build that, we're going to go
ahead and make a MotionLayout.
This is a subclass of
ConstraintLayout.  It has a
layout tag. Here, I'm going to
call it spacing.  Then I have to
define my layout, which is just
the views.  I don't give it
widths and heights, I don't
constrain anything.  I'm
literally just going to make a
list of three text views and an
image view.
Now I'm going to go to the file
I was talking about earlier.
This is the motion scene file.
Inside that, it defines a
transition and a transition has
a start and an end.  Again,
that's the thing that defines an
animation.  An animation always
has a beginning and it always
has an end.  To define start,
I'm going to make a constraint
set and a constraint set is just
a tag.  It has an
ide -- ID.
But, we'll say which ID, I'm
going to set its height, width
and padding.  I'll constrain --
to push it off the screen, I'm
going to constrain to the end of
parent and do the same thing for
the constrain set, end.  I'm
going to go ahead and make the
title view constrain the start
to the start of parent.  And
this brings that title on to the
screen.  I'm going to do the
same thing for all the other
views in this layout, as well.
It's a clarity of XML and I
built this animation.
So now I'm going to pass it back
to Chris, who's going to talk a
little bit more about --
The motion editor.  So, at I/O
this year, we gave you a sneak
peek of the motion editor.
We've been working pretty hard
on it but it's not quit ready
yet.  We wanted to make sure
that we focus on getting some
foundational pieces in place
before we release it.  We don't
want to be too impatient and get
it right, unlike things like
instant run.
[Laughter]
The motion library has been out
for awhile.  We wanted to nail
the right animation concepts and
roles required.  The library
also needs to be
performant.
John and Nicolas has been
working hard on the library.
They love your feedback and all
the cool demos that have been
coming out.  So, please, keep it
coming and thank you.
The other thing is the quality
of Android Studio.  It's been
the primary focus for us in 3.3
and the upcoming 3.4 release.
We've made performance and
interactions improvements
because it has to be able to
render animations at 60 frames
per second and making it easier
to work with constraints because
you have to know how to use
ConstraintLayout and so we think
that if we invest in the quality
now in the tool, it will
actually make the MotionLayout
editor better With that, I'm
here to show you very early
exploration of the motion
editor.  This is mockups, not
the build.  I'm the designer.
This is all made in Photo
Shop.
Feel free to find me or Sean
and I think John's here, too.
If we take the example from
before we have the space picture
and text views animating in,
let's use that as the context of
what we'll see in the motion
editor.  So, what does that
actually look like?  So, here,
we have a new perspective on the
component tree, for now we're
calling the transitions view.
For the purpose of the talk, I'm
going to talk about this new
view because we think this is
the most significant  KNT part.
You'll have the property panel
and pallet.  We haven't quite
figured out the details about
how that integrates with the
timeline or view.  So, stay
tuned for that.
So, in this case, we have the
start of the transition and so
you can see the text views are
off the view port but you can
see there's a motion path that
goes from outside and in.  We
don't actually render the text
views outside the view port
today, but that's definitely
something we will need to have
for animation because we know
that's a very typical animation
example to have things fly in.
And so if we kind of fast
forward halfway through the
transition, you can see the text
views have moved halfway in and
we have the space image zoomed
back out and that's kind of what
we intended here.  So, if we
rewind, let's go deeper on what
this transition view actually
does.  So, we're only showing
one transition now and it's
uniquely named by its start and
end constraint set.  You can
have multiple transitions per
MotionLayout and so with this
drop-down, you'll be able to
switch between the different
transitions and we'll load the
corresponding constraint sets
and change the timelines so you
can see how the components
change.
Each transition has its own
properties, which is the start
and end constraint set.  It has
duration expressed in
milliseconds.
So, if we move down, we have the
timeline.  And so you have,
starting from the left, you have
the play back bar, you can loop
the animation as many times as
you want.  You can quickly jump
to the start or the end.  If you
want to speed up or slow down
the animation, we allow that, as
well.  Just to tune the
animation perfectly.
And we have this time control
here so you can actually step
through millisecond, by
millisecond and then for the
timeline itself, you know, we
show from zero to 100, 100 being
the end.  You can use this
slider here to make the timeline
bigger or smaller depending on
which part of the transition you
want to focus on.
And so we move down and see all
the components that you can
animate in the MotionLayout.
Each component will show they
have a start and end constrain
set, which are required to
animate anything.  And so if we
look specifically at this space
flash image, it has a key
attribute or key frame which we
will change halfway through the
animation.
If we zoom out, they corresponds
sponds to the same ones.  Here's
my components I'm animating and
where they're starting and
ending and what are the actual
motion paths.
And so, that's kind of where we
are with the motion editor.  We
hope to get it out soon, but I
can't promise anything.
Next year.
[Laughter]
Some time in 2019.  And that's
it.
[Applause]
Everyone, the next session, in
this theater, will begin at
5:40.  Thank you.
Welcome back, everyone.  The
program is going to get under
way in about two minutes.  Our
program will resume in two and a
half minutes.
[No audio]
In the end, I will talk about
what we're working on.  Two
years ago, Google CEO we'll move
to mobile-first world.  It means
machine learning and mobile.
Years and years, more and more
mobile apps are using machine
learning to produce fascinateg
user experience.  More and more
machine learning logic is
shifting from the server running
the cloud to the mobile device
in your pocket.  It has many
fast,advantages.  It's it does
not need to spend costs.  It
also runs anytime, anywhere,
with and without network
connectivity.  It also provides
better production for user
privacy since the data does not
have to leave the device.  Let
me take a quick poll here.  How
many of you traveled from
outside of California to attend
this dev summit?  Wow!  Welcome.
Welcome to Silicon Valley.  I
hope you get a chance to visit
Golden Gate Bridge and enjoy
good food.
Talking about food, my
biological watch tells me it's
time for dinner.  So, where
should I eat?  Well, I'll pull
out my phone, ask Google
Assistant.  Hi, Google, I'm
hungry.  Any good restaurants
around here?  They recommend
where to go for dinner around
the area and location I'm
currently at.  When I tell it a
new place, I would like to take
a lot of photos.
Mobile device can now run really
increasingly for  machine
learning tasks.  Last spring, I
took my family to Tuscany in
Italy.  We drove around those
beautiful hilltop towns.  There
are many signs, but I don't
speak Italian, unfortunately.  I
wish I do.  How do I know what
it means?  Here's where Google
Translate came to
rescue.  It will use a natural
language processing to translate
the text from one language into
another.
Finally, it uses speech to
convert text into voice and tell
me what the sign is, in my own
language.
All these involve machine
learning.  There is a seamless
and powerful user experience.
This all look great.  But as a
developer, how do I do something
like this?
Machine learning requires
specialized knowledge and years
of experience.  It requires a
large amount of good
high-quality data.
The mobile device has very
limited computing power.  Models
run on a server in the cloud are
often too large or too complex.
You need to spend a lot of
effort to optimize model for the
mobile usage.  After, finally,
the app is built, you need to
worry about how do I deploy,
that becomes another headache.
Take all these problems, we
launched ML Kit, which helps the
mobile developers build Android
and OS apps using machine
learning technologies.
ML Kit is aimed at making
machine learning easy for mobile
developers just because you want
to use machine learning on
mobile, it does not mean you
need to worry about collecting
data, building models,
optimizing, hosting, deployment,
downloading.  ML Kit will take
care of all of this for you.  We
provide common models that work
out of box.  They optimized for
speed, accuracy and efficiency
for the mobile device.
We provide one consistent API
across both Android
and i OS.
For commonly-needed machine
learning tasks, we have base API
that come with pretrained Google
models that work out of the box.
There are five APIs we're
supporting.  The test
recognition API are on the
ondevice and cloud.  It can
recognize Latin
characters and a wide range of
languages and special
characters.
Face detection is API the
support to have faces in image
and well as live video
streaming.  We have contour
detection which can help you
identify different parts of the
face and then apply face mask.
The barcode scanning can be used
to detect one-dimensional and
two-dimensional barcodes.  Image
labeling API can detect objects
inside the photo.  For ondevice
and the cloud.  The ondevice
covers most of the common things
you see in photos.  While the
cloud API can support 10,000
labels across many categories.
Finally, our landmark API can
recognize well-known places in
the photo, like White House or
Eiffel Tower.  If this does not
fit your need and you're an
experienced developer with the
knowledge on how to build and
train models, you're more than
welcome to bring your own Custom
Model.  We run it on TensorFlow.
It is an open source framework
for learning and TensorFlow Lite
is optimized for mobile
platforms.  For models trained
with TensorFlow, we provide your
tools to convert and compress
into a format.  While you're
using Custom Model, you can do
it inside your app or host it in
the cloud.  If you choose the
latter option to host in the
cloud, it does not mean you need
to build your own cloud server.
ML Kit will find a way for you.
We will manage the model
hosting, deployment,
downloading, upgrade and the
ongoing experimentation.
Since ML Kit was launched six
months ago at the Google I/O, we
have made several enhancements.
First, we greatly-enhanced our
face detention model, which is
now 18 times faster and 13% to
24% more accurate.  We also
polished our text recognition
API by making them more
streamlined and consistent
across both ondevice and the
cloud.  In addition, we launched
face contour detection.  You can
see now you can use the API to
identify the contours of the
face in the photo.  It includes
the entire face, both eyebrows,
eyes, nose and lips. This is
where the realtime apps can put
the face mask like a goggle or
some funny nose on the face and
make the mask move with the face
in the live video streaming.
Next, I'm going to share some
tips and practices for how to
use ML Kit so I can build
impressive mobile apps using
machine
learning.
Poor image focus can hurt the
accuracy.  Second, you should
ensure the image has sufficient
size.  For example, for face
detection, you should have at
least 100-by 100 pixels for each
face.  If you want detection in
the selfie mode, it should be
200-by-200.  For language API,
it should be 16-by-16 in size.
If you use our cloud API to
recognize Chinese, Japanese and
Korean, each character should be
at least 24-by-24.  Similarly,
barcode has the size
requirement.  Please check out
online documentation for more
details.
Machine learning and libraries
can be large, which can slow
down the app download.  There
are two ways to reduce the APK
size.  First, you can build your
app as an Android App Bundle.
By doing that, you enable Google
Play to automatically generate
APKs for specific screen
density, architecture as well as
the languages.  Your user only
have to download the APK and
match their device configuration
Another way you can reduce API14
RR RR size is if it is not a
primary purpose, you could move
machine learning features, which
require ML Kit into a dynamic
feature model.  That way, you
prevent users for downloading
model, which sometimes can be
large.
We all know machine learning
involves a lot of computation,
so, the speed becomes really
important.  Here are tips on how
to improve.  You can reduce the
image resolution and video frame
rate to limit amount of
computation it involves.  When
the current frame speed process,
you should also throttle
incoming video frames, which
increases memory, as well as
slow down the performance.
For realtime face detection, you
should use face fast mode, which
luckily is the default mode.
Often times, resolution is
sufficient for face detection.
For realtime processing, you
should also choose between
contour detection versus
classification or landmark
detection, but not both.
Because doing both could be
expensive and may not be fit for
the realtime processing of the
slow device.
Another tip and trick you should
use is, you should wait for
detection to finish before
rendering the face and contour
together.  You can check out our
online quickstart app on GitHub
for more details.
To illustrate what I mean, I
will do a live demo.  Let's
switch to the demo mode.  So,
for the purpose of demo, I'm
using slower, 3-year-old
Nexus 5 X phone.  In the first
video, I'm going to show you,
without any tips and we do not
do video -- any drawing to make
sure the contour and the face
are together so if you just call
the API without any performance
improvement, you can see, the
contours are not full in the
face.  And there's a big gap
between these two.
All right.  So, now I switch to
another version, after applying
performance tips.
In this version, it's using the
exact same Nexus 5X
phone.  Also, we wait for the
detection to finish before
render both the face and the
contour.  As you can see now,
the contours are full in the
face all the time.  There's no
more gap.  Cool.
So, let's switch back to
the slides.
[Applause]
If you're using our Custom Model
API, how to include model is
something you should consider.
There are two ways, you can
bundle inside your app or host
it on the cloud.  If you bundle
your model on the
app, it's available immediately.
It doesn't need any downloading.
You get a bigger app because app
contains the model.  It may slow
down the app download.  Also,
you cannot change the model
without a new app release.  On
the other hand, if you host a
model in the cloud, we provide
all the hosting support for you.
You get a smaller app size
because the app does not contain
the model, which translates into
a faster installation.  You also
can choose the download model
only if it's needed.  The model
updates can come over the air
into the app without any new app
release.
You can also use remote config
and AB testing provided by
Firebase.  The drawback of
hosting model on the cloud is,
obviously, it means
connectivity.  When there's no
connectivity, you cannot
download the model.  Also, the
model will not be available
until they're downloaded.
So, a third option is using a
hybrid approach.  You can bundle
the model in the app, so make it
usable right away.  Then you can
receive model updates over the
air from the cloud.  If you're
using our base API, it's
provided in two different forms.
For the better terms, SDK.  The
model's actually provided by the
Google Play service so it's
across all apps so the app,
itself, does not have to contain
the model, which will make your
app smaller.  Text recognition
are provided through the SDK.
The second type is thick SDKs.
The models are bound inside the
SDK.  Each app will have their
own copy of the model, which
will increase the app size.
Face detection and image
labeling are supported through
the thick SDKs.
To use this type of SDK and SDKs
provided by the ML Kit, you need
to include the appropriate ML
Kit dependancies in your app.
Inside that file, inside this
dependency section, if you want
to use the API support through
the thin SDK, you should add the
dependency called Firebase.  And
in addition, if you want to use
thick SDK, you should still keep
this line, because all the API
entry points are coming from
this thing SDK dependency.  But
you also need to add additional
dependancies.  If you want to
use image recognition, image
detection, then you need to add
the firebase ML vision because
it's a thick SDK.
Similarly, for image labeling,
you need to add image label
model dependency.
Next, I will talk about a few
new areas we're currently
working on.  A few new ML Kit
features are either under
development or in early testing
phase.  We started with natural
language processes.  We have
smart replies.  We are also
planning to go into other areas,
like speech.  At the same time,
we will continue to enhance
performance and accuracy of base
APIs.
We launched model compression
and conversion service to our
alpha services, which helped
them to convert and compress
large model into a smaller and
faster versions for mobile
usage.  The conversion service
is alpha, using pruning,
quantization and transfer
learning to retrain the large
models, make them smaller and
faster without sacrificing too
much accuracy
YAERS.
Fishbrain allows you to share
the photos of your catch.  It
can identify any fish with a
photo.  Their model is more
than 80 megabytes.  By using our
conversion and compression, they
were able to reduce it.  They
only maintain the same level of
accuracy, it is slightly better.
If you are interested in trying
out our model compression
service, please join our alpha
program by signing up today at
g.co/firebase/sign-up.
I hope you enjoyed the talk
today and can take home some
tips and I can't wait to see
what you will build with ML Kit.
If you have questions, I'll be
outside in the lounge and we'll
also be in office hours.  Thanks
so much for listening.
[Applause]
Hi, everyone.  Welcome to
Modern Android Notifications.
My name is Jingyu.
I'm Paul Matthews.  I'm a
developer advocate in London.
So, three years ago, on this
stage, Chris Ren gave this quote
and it's a brilliant one.  Don't
annoy in user, respect them,
empower them, delight them,
connect them to the people they
care about.  And this is still
very much true today.  So, we'll
look at channels and how you can
use them in your app.  What's
new in notifications and
finally, digital well-being.
First, how to respect your
users.  So respect your user's
attention.  Don't annoy the
user, respect them.  Some useful
tips, so do respect the user's
settings.  So, if they've
communicated to you, in your
app, that they want a certain
setting for your notifications,
then you should respect that.
Don't try and override it.
Don't try and ignore it.  You
should check that the
notifications you're sending are
not blocked.  That they do still
want to hear these
notifications.  And finally, if
you're capable in your app, you
should back up any settings they
have told you about
notifications and make sure
they're synced over install
and devices.
You should use well-structured
apps, making use of the styles,
such as messaging style, inbox
style, big-picture style.  You
should make sure your
notifications are timely.  Using
high priority messages to ensure
they get your messages when you
in tend them to get your
notifications.  And prioritize
the notifications and making
them look better.
So some don'ts, don't send these
notifications and forget about
them.  We want you to use the
platform features that are there
to help you.  For instance, auto
cancel, making sure they
disappear.  Timeouts, is it
relevant after four hours?  And
synchronizing across the
devices.  If you know they use
your app on multiple devices,
you should try and synchronize
notifications they read on one.
So don't send notifications that
are not actionable.  The point
of notifications is that they're
there to be used.  By
definition, the user wants to
know something, which means they
generally need to do something.
So don't send them a
notification that says, hey, we
synced some things in the
background.
Don't annoy in user, use alert
once and don't make sure they're
getting buzzed crazy while
they're standing up on stage,
presenting about notifications.
Make sure it is representative
of what you want.  If you're a
chat app, maybe children group
notification behavior.
So, respect the user, otherwise,
they might just
turn off your notifications and
they might choose to uninstall
your app, which would be far
worse.
There are platform features that
deliberately enable
notifications being turned off.
For instance, notifications are
being posted and the users maybe
keep swiping it away and so now,
in P, we prompt the user, do you
really care about this
notification?  Do you really
want to see this content?  This
acts on channels if you're not
describing your channels
correctly, this can lead to some
confusion and perhaps some lost
notifications.
So, let's look more at
notifications channels.  They
provide granular control.
Channels are the way to empower
them.  So let's look at how to
use them.  First of all, they're
now required on all apps, as
we've -- they're required on API
26 and that should be
everywhere.  They help the user
categorize.  So they help you
categorize your notifications
that help the user to interact
with them.
And finally, they allow the user
to customize their settings.
So, the user has the final say.
So, if you think something's
important and they don't think
it is, they can tell you this.
So, let's look at the best
practices.  Again, you should
allow the users to manage their
notifications through the
channel creation.  You should
allow them to maybe deep link
into settings to change these
things, if they're expressing an
interest of working with your
notifications channels, perhaps
they want to be able to change
the importance of something.
So, setting the right importance
level for a notification channel
seems like an obvious one, but
it's so easy to overlook.
User settings, you should
respect the user settings, but
back them up when you can and
don't try to abuse them by
deleting and re-creating.
Other don'ts are only using one
channel.  This is a clear
notification smell, if you like.
If you've only got one channel
in your application, there's
probably something else you need
to be looking at.  If you
provide poor descriptions for
users so they don't understand
the uses of a channel, they
won't be able to able.  If you
use wrong or blocked channels.
They're trying to communicate to
you that that don't like this
content and you should respect
that.
Spamming the user with
notification channels is not the
best way to proceed.
Choosing your channels carefully
can help.  Think of your users
when you choose your channels.
Think of the user and how they
might want to interact with your
app.  For instance, it's a bad
idea to create channels around
your importance level.  This
isn't what notification channels
are for.  You should group them
around categories like tagging
in a photo, tagged posts.
You should also think about
creating notifications when
there's more control needed.
For instance, if I'm on a chat
app and have a general channel
the all chat notifications
coming in but then I express an
interest in controlling a family
chat group, you should create a
channel and allow the user to
dive deeper and have
more control.
Lazily creating, that is if they
don't receive a message through
your app, you don't need to
create the channel for that.
And then, the user can provide
feedback to you, to say, look,
this is useful or this isn't
useful and you should listen to
that.  So, in Android P, we
added broadcasts for listening
in to blocking -- to blocking or
changing state of your
notification channels.  You
should understand those and you
should react to them.  You
should maybe back them up so the
next time you create a channel
on a different device, it makes
sense.
You can query these APIs at
runtime, also, to find out how
the user interacts with your
channels.
So, now look at what's new in
notifications.
Thank you, Paul.  Okay.  Now
let's look at what else is new
in notifications in Android 9.
We added updates to make the
notifications easier to read and
scan through.  We added more
padding notifications and we
went back to using the rounded
corners at the top and bottom.
They love the smooth app opening
animation you are seeing here on
the slide instead of closing the
notification and opening the
app, now the notification goes
smoothly in the app.  You need
to make sure you're starting
your activity directly and your
active starts quickly.
Since, for most users, the
notification they care about the
most are the ones connecting
them with the people they care,
so we enhanced our messaging
style.  Messaging experience, by
adding a new person class.  Once
you use API 28 and if you're
using MessagingStyle in
notification, we have now moved
people's Avatar to the left of
the notification and you can set
that Avatar by using the set
icon method.
We also added support for images
and stickers in the messages
notification by using set data,
you can add image in your
messages notification directly.
The other feature that I love,
on Android, is direct reply.
But come times when I'm replying
to a notification, I would
accidentally tap on the
notification and that will open
the app and my response is lost.
Android 9, you can help the user
with this.  By retrieving the
draft, you can populate the
response in your app.  So, make
the user experience better,
delight them.
If you already support smart
reply in your app, we
highly-recommend you use this
API to also display them in your
notification.  Instead of
replying to the notification,
user can now just tap one of
them and to reply.
Okay.  Here's an example we have
for using the new APIs.  First,
we're going to create an
instance -- person instance
here.  So, we're going do use
the person.  We are setting the
name, the URI, the icon for this
person and this is going to
represent the center in the
message. And then, we're going
to pass that to this message
that we're creating here.  As
you can see, we're passing the
instance of the person, not like
before where we were passing the
name of that person.  We also
want to include the image, so
we're using the set data method
to include that image.
And then after that, we're
adding this message with another
message so we're adding two
messages into this
MessagingStyle notification and
we're setting the style into our
notification.
Okay.  So, here's a quick
summary of some of the dos and
don'ts when you're using
MessagingStyle.  First, please
use MessagingStyle for messages.
And this also applies for if
you're using Android Auto or
Android Wear.  If you're
ascending messaging
notifications, please use
MessagingStyle.  In the past,
we've seen developers switching
between MessagingStyles in order
to that big image expansion
presentation.  But now, with set
data method, you don't need to
do that.  You can use
MessagingStyle and this will
create a consistent experience
for the user.
And it's always good to add the
icon for the people in the
notification so we
highly-recommend you use that to
add the Avatar.  If you don't
set it, we'll use the initial of
the person's name.  And finally,
if your app supports smart
reply, please add that into your
notification so you're creating
a better experience for in user.
And here's a few things you want
to avoid.  There are a lot of
good reasons to Auto-cancel a
notification.  In order to give
the user a clean and up-to-date
notification jar, after they
reply to a messaging
notification, this is not one of
those cases.  You would want to
keep that notification there so
if the user wants to reply to
this conversation and reply
afterwards so please don't
cancel that and let the user
swipe away when they're finished
with the conversation.
The other bad behavior that
we've seen in the past is some
developers are setting this in
order to achieve a visual
presentation.  Please don't do
that.  There are two reasons.
One is because it will break
Android 9 on the presentation
and the other -- and the other
reason is because a person
without a name is not a real
person.
[Laughter]
So, up until now, we've talked
about how you can reach the user
-- how you can help your user
connect with people they care
about and how you can make your
notification a better experience
for the user but I want to hit a
pause here and look at app usage
from the other side.  Since as
much as I want to get that
notification from my friend and
family, I still need need time
away from the device.
So, to help user with this, we
announced the digital well-being
at I/O this year.  If you have a
device running Android 9, I
highly-recommend you download it
from the Play store and sign up
for beta.
So, this is what digital
well-being will show us.  It
provides an overview of our app
usage and provides a dashboard
that shows our time spending on
each app and the number of
notifications we've received.  I
personally love to use it to
learn where I'm spending my time
but sometimes I would see some
apps are sending me
notifications unexpectedly.  One
question you might have is how
are the notifications counted?
The goal is to track user
interruptinterruptions.  Any
updates that's visible to the
user are counted as one.  If
you're sending a notification to
the block channel, that is not
counted here.
So, in this case, I saw this app
is sending me lots of
notifications so I got curious.
I went into the dashboard and I
opened that to see the hourly
breakdown.  And as you can see
here, I got a notification every
hour that day and even at 4:00
a.m. in the morning, I got eight
notifications.  So if this
notification are high
importance, I would be woken up
in the middle of the night.
Thankfully, that's not the case.
But if these notifications are
push notifications and they are
sent uses high priority message,
which means this app is
constantly waking up a deep-dose
device.  If I want to have good
battery in the morning, I might
uninstall this app.  For now, I
will turn on D&D so I don't get
disturbed.
It provides ways for users to
disconnect and reduce
interruption.  You can turn it
on by flipping your device,
which is super convenient.  But
what if this is super important
notification that the user
actually wants to receive?  So
for those, here's the few advice
for you.  First, set the right
category to your notification.
As we can see here, in the do
not disturb setting, user can
choose what to block and what to
allow and set exceptions on
calls, reminders and events. If
your notification belongs to one
of them, please tag your
notification as such.
Here, I listed a few categories
which corresponds to the
exceptions on the other side.
As I said, if your notification
belongs to one of these
categories, please let us know
by tagging them.
The other advice that we have is
if this is a notification coming
from another person, please tag
your notification. As you can
see here, in the digtell -- user
can choose who they want to get
notified from.  So, please add
that person in your notification
and add the associated
URI, if possible.  You'll bypass
Do Not Disturb.  When user turn
it on, they really don't want to
be disturbed.  So if you're
sending a notification that's
not expected, that will really
annoy them.  So please don't
abuse these APIs.
This brings us back to the code
we have at the beginning.
Whenever you're sending a
notification, don't annoy the
user, respect them, empower
them, delight them and connect
them to the people they care
about.
Thank you.
[Applause]